[Laughter]
okay here we are it's wednesday night
we're getting some drinks going
and as always like two or three minutes
before we started the stream some weird
[ __ ] happened yeah
cops showed up
cops standing out there with a [ __ ]
gun and [ __ ]
i have no door like what's up
is your alarm going off i was like
alarm i don't have an alarm
and [ __ ] you know he goes you know
how alarmist is yeah no going on i said
you can come in if you want and i showed
him there's an alarm on the wall but
that alarm hasn't worked since we've
been here yeah we never we never
activated it yeah
so he's like they must have given me the
wrong house number i guess so 6113 yeah
because i'm pretty sure we don't have an
alarm
we don't learn and uh you know yeah it's
and
even if we did it it looks like you know
even if we did have an alarm that we
didn't know about
um you know no nobody's in here but uh
just us so
we're almost never not in here
maybe the poltergeist set off an alarm
they set for the cops
[Laughter]
oh my god
yeah dj maniac said tom talk too much
[ __ ] on youtube and the feds are after
them that's probably what you thought
when you saw the cops right no
you thought they were coming to get you
a local city cop
yeah
that's really weird all i heard somebody
knocking at the door and i thought it
was just like a package or something and
then like i heard something about alarm
alarm and i was just kind of like what
what are you talking about and then he
was like we don't have an alarm i didn't
know it was the cops
but yeah uh sorry i'm just laughing at
sandra's screen name again sandra
wonders if seaman has healing properties
[Laughter]
their screen name yeah
i know i didn't see anything like that
no well that was something that we were
talking about on um chip man what show
was it that we were talking about that
or somebody it was on the women in
mental health show where they thought
that uh you know women went crazy
because
you know if they had if they had sex
with their husbands and they imparted
their healing semen to them then it
would make them better and if they
didn't get that then that made them
crazy
so you know all right
there's some other [ __ ] that was going
on in the [ __ ] fitness world i'm
going to talk about now uh oh
well can i can i
uh just before we get too much into it
i'm not naming any names but
uh you know how we've had like a bunch
of stupid random ass like trolls around
here seems like i think some of the
maybe um
people that come here a lot like have
been trolling under different names too
and i would really appreciate like you
not doing that because
you know it's it's kind of not cool and
i think i know who it is and um you know
and i just well it's like you know
sometimes it's like we're doing a show
it's like we want to hang out with you
guys it's like
you know it's cool to have like
conversations and stuff but then if
somebody's in there like incognito like
under a different name i don't know who
the [ __ ] that you are
and um you know and they're just coming
in like saying crazy [ __ ] like trying to
be funny or whatever and i'm just kind
of like yeah i probably know who it is
and i'm like i don't know i just don't
know a lot of people don't do that kind
of stuff anyway
and i want to and i want to give a shout
out to uh michael e because he's here is
he is here my player oh wait a minute
about that package yeah yeah just wait
until more people show up man all right
all right all right all right we got him
we got it michael w we're gonna show it
later on
because it's still kind of early on in
the night
they had a dude who um
on the bodybuilding on the bodybuilding
channels on youtube there's this dude
who made a big name for himself
he was saying
that a human sperm
was a performance-enhancing drug if you
drank it and he was drinking this other
dude's jizz
yeah yeah the other dude was like on
could it be that he just wanted to drink
someone else's jizz and like wanted to
come up with some justification for it
i'm not judging well he was saying
saying that that dude was that dude was
[ __ ] hulking out on steroids so it
would be like [ __ ]
you had you'd have to be gay to [ __ ]
do that [ __ ] you got to be but he wasn't
saying that and and people were thinking
that he was trolling but he was just
another
kind of fitness dude you know jim jim
rat dude and he was saying he was doing
he was trying to measure his gains i
think it was a troll
well it might just yeah it's it's just
somebody that is trying to make a name
for themselves and like stand out by
doing something like outrageousness
which
but they were trying to analyze you know
what i mean if i could he was a talk of
the town for a while they haven't heard
him talked about in the past couple
months but anytime that dude would post
a video
and [ __ ] you know he would claim it
was in it he claimed he was drinking it
don't even don't like describe it too
much because i'm kind of like nauseated
[Laughter]
he's like and then he would [ __ ]
explain what it was doing you know what
i mean and [ __ ] how it was causing
[ __ ] like a hormonal feedback and
stuff to get you to produce more
testosterone it just
it was just [ __ ] funny though i
didn't believe it
well i hope not because that sounds like
uh he might have been doing it well yeah
i'm not well i don't believe that that
that it was a performance-enhancing drug
i don't even know if i believe he was
doing it he was just kind of like making
people believe that so many cause so
everybody because like i said that kind
of [ __ ] goes viral because everybody's
like look at this crazy [ __ ] yeah i
forgot dude's name somebody but some of
you don't encourage him might know who
that was
don't give people like that attention
yeah it just encourages them to do
stupider [ __ ] there's enough stupidity
in the world we don't need more
oh my god
uh oracle said years ago there was
somebody who put together a cookbook
called cooking with semen or something
like that
yeah i've seen um
i've seen i don't know if there's a
cookbook but i know that there was kind
of like a weird like mini trend or
something i don't know it was a trend
but there's a couple people doing it
where women were like eating their
afterbirth
or something
i remember something about that was a
long time ago though but it's like like
i said it's always kind of one of those
things that
you know the crazy or something it is
something is you know the more the media
is gonna because it's like a crazy story
and everybody's gonna click on it right
but it's like how many people are
actually doing that probably not that
many but it's just kind of like because
the story gets picked up it looks like
ooh it's this big trend and i'm sure
it's not i'm sure it's just like one
idiot like doing it and then
or maybe a couple idiots doing it and
then just like everybody wants to report
on it because it's idiotic
grampur's hammer said i'll have to tell
uh my wife about the positive attributes
of drinking my spunk
yeah i'm so gross
you can find that [ __ ] on youtube
[ __ ] gross
dude is acting totally serious
but i i i think he was looking [ __ ]
but he he had all these other
bodybuilders talking about it trying to
disprove what he was saying
hmm
maybe we should do some stupid come up
with like some really really stupid
thing you see derek derek from more
plates more dates he's he's like a
[ __ ] muscle nerd and he knows all
those drugs he can tell you he reads all
the damn studies on him how the
endocrine system works he'll [ __ ]
make a whole map of what does what and
[ __ ]
how testosterone aromatizes into
estrogen blah blah blah blah he's not
making it up he's read all the stuff you
know that's his [ __ ] hobby he's a
he's a damn muscle nerd
and he went through the science and he's
like no
no it couldn't be
you know there's because even if there
was even if there was something in there
that it would just be trace amounts it
would be it wouldn't be enough to make
any difference you wouldn't be able to
measure any difference well i mean that
should be obvious right
to anybody with the smallest modicum of
scientific knowledge right so there
wouldn't be enough difference in there
to make you it wouldn't make any
difference yeah
uh i also wanted to say uh good luck
congratulations whatever to oracle about
uh she's talking about a job yeah she's
up for
so
hopefully that goes the way you want it
to go
uh mark navarro says you have to eat
your own poop to get all the nutrients
that's why cows have four stomachs
hitler was eating [ __ ] you guys know
that
that sounds like something he would do
well he didn't know he was eating [ __ ]
though he had a dog
he had a doctor who was a [ __ ] quack
all right and his name was morel
and morel was a real famous syphilis
doctors which is kind of strange because
it kind of it kind of goes into with
with the rumor that hitler had syphilis
which he he had a lot of
symptoms of [ __ ] late stage with
syphilis in remission
but this guy was giving him something
called vitamin b
all right morel would just keep him
[ __ ] jacked up on all kinds of drugs
especially towards the last few years of
his life
but he was giving him this [ __ ]
concoction he was making it called
vitamultin beef
and it was in a little wrapper he had to
unwrap it he had it all wrapped in gold
gold foil leaf especially for adult
filler and [ __ ] and he'd unwrap it and
it'd be like a little pellet that he
made
it was methamphetamine some [ __ ]
herbs and some special [ __ ] from
special human [ __ ] from some
peasants over in
[ __ ]
hungary or something that we're eating
something that this dr morrell thought
was
therapeutic he had some of that some of
those people's [ __ ] in it
or sarah poopik they're pooping yeah
know
there's a lot of crazy [ __ ] you're
making me gag yeah there's a lot of
there's over the years there's been a
lot of crazy accusations of stories made
up about things that happened over there
[ __ ] you know with all in in the
third reich [ __ ] with old old mustache
man
but a lot of it was [ __ ] [ __ ]
that came up after the war but no there
that was true and that was some there
was some weird [ __ ] that they did
you know
a lot of them were drug addicts a lot of
people don't know that
well like
in a lot of ways it's funny they're
talking about the good old days but a
lot of well it was it was almost like
more acceptable to be a drug addict back
then because a lot of them were legal
yeah sandra said isn't there a coffee
thing that comes out of cat poop there
is um there's this kind of like gourmet
is it a civic cat i want to say
um
or something
yeah they made coffee out of some cash
[ __ ] remember that that was like super
fan i don't know if that was might have
been like a i think you're right i think
it was a civic cat i think it's some
seeds that they eat
yeah they eat some seeds and [ __ ] it out
something like that and it doesn't that
the the the digestive tract doesn't
destroy the seed yeah it weakens it or
something
and you can now take that seed and and
wash it off and they collect all the
[ __ ] out of this [ __ ] civic cat [ __ ]
and they wash those seeds off and sell
them to make coffee with it's like a
real expensive gourmet coffee
that's got to be some real good cover i
can't imagine
um
how good that coffee would be to one for
me to pay that much money for it which i
can't afford and two just think that it
came out of a cat's butthole but you
know what i mean
uh oracle said there is such a thing as
a fecal transplant yes that's true
if you don't have the right uh flora and
stuff in your intestines and it's
causing you problems or illnesses they
can actually implant like other
uh poop molecules into your intestines
like to kind of get your own floral up i
don't think they make you eat it though
unless they put it in a capsule form i
think they just kind of like i don't
know if they stick it up your butt i'm
not really sure how they do it my sister
would probably know she used to she used
to work billing at a giant clinic
so she has all kind of fun stories she
doesn't anymore but she used to
so she's got all the poop stories and
all the like funny [ __ ] stuck up
people's butts stories
uh must be a sidetrack show if we're
talking about eating poop and so you
know what i mean it seems like this is
kind of the topic that we would wander
into later when we were kind of like
slightly hammered but it's like no man
we haven't we haven't been on for like
15 minutes and we're already talking
about poop
they also make perfume with skunk pee
yes they do
um yeah they make all kind of like
honestly i think um
i read a couple books about perfumery
and about like them making perfume and
stuff there are actually like a lot of
things that are made with like really
really gross like a lot of perfume
ingredients that are made with really
gross
pee and poop and various other kinds of
things
they're laughing
they said he laughed when i said that he
hit the right [ __ ] he did
and he probably didn't know though
dr morrell knew
but he wasn't trying to [ __ ] with him
it was
morel was a [ __ ] quack
he was a [ __ ] quack
he did all kinds of [ __ ]
the reason why i mentioned him is that
there was some programs about that and
there was even a whole book written
about morel
and how
morel may have partially been
a contributing factor to to the final
solution or you know or the holocaust
because
that [ __ ] morel was keeping him just
loaded up with all kinds of [ __ ]
methamphetamine
and a bunch of opiates too you get they
were giving him morphine all the time
they'd knock him out with morphine and
in the morning they'd wake him up with
methamphetamine
and then he had real bad constipation
you know hitler couldn't take a [ __ ] so
then they'd give him all kinds of weird
laxatives
and he was a vegetarian which made it
worse so he had real [ __ ] bad gas he
had real bad teeth
a lot of people don't realize that the
fewer [ __ ] has terrible teeth
and um
for some reason it makes me really
really happy to think that that stupid
[ __ ] was just like sitting
around the toilet all the time
like suffering it was like good
it was mostly the last like two years
still that's good that's a long time two
years suffer [ __ ] he went he went crazy
i think um when uh he went [ __ ] crazy
we lost the german army over the battle
of stalingrad
operation barbara elsa [ __ ] failed he
[ __ ] over a million men got [ __ ]
killed up there they never came back and
they said he was never really the same
after that he was
you know two years you know spent the
second or the last two years of his life
just totally doped up and [ __ ]
he was either knocked out
on morphine or he was just in this total
manic state because they were just
giving him a lot of methamphetamine
he wasn't making a whole lot of sense
and
he had tertiary [ __ ] syphilis in
remission once once he made his mind up
to do something he couldn't change his
mind and that's
that's that's the symptoms of syphilis
in remission
which is they're kind of
robotic and lizard-like once they come
to a conclusion they can't reverse a
decision
you know you'll run into people like
that sometimes it doesn't necessarily
mean that they have that but it's one of
the symptoms of
probably what was wrong with him
but
so really medical
the way the way he's being treated
medically could have
affected a lot of what happened
in germany i mean um
you know the high command was [ __ ] up
too
um
they were they they were all in a big
damn circle jerk
those guys
they couldn't back off anything they
didn't want to look like a [ __ ] and
there's a lot of peer pressure and [ __ ]
going on between them
a lot of and there was a lot of
backstabbing they were catty [ __ ]
making fun of each other and [ __ ] all
the time and big time yeah
uh but yeah well that's kind of the
thing it's like i totally i was gonna
say something i totally forgot what it
was oh well um
there was a group synergy between people
can become very dangerous
yeah uh hugo asked do you think hitler
really committed suicide
um well i i know a lot about it um
probably yeah probably
he wasn't the kind of guy to be taken
alive he knew what happened to mussolini
he wasn't going to let that happen to
himself
and uh he was so s
pig-headed really and strong-willed he
couldn't retreat he had to kill himself
and which was common in in the german
military anyway a lot of the generals
did kill themselves
um
if they were lost a battle down eastern
front and all hope is lost and they
felt like you know
they were kind of like the japanese
committing hair carry they were they
were like that
they were like i failed at my duty bam
didn't want to go in his face yeah they
were like that
yeah i could see that
but uh no what i was gonna say was that
well here's something else though
there's another big contributing factor
that
here in the comfortable west
you don't [ __ ] read into it this war
was in the end happening inside of
germany germany was just being [ __ ]
destroyed
parts of it looked like the damn surface
of the moon from the point of view of
your average german citizen it was the
apocalypse there wasn't it wasn't a
future
and
they were going [ __ ] crazy old people
were committing suicides jumping off of
bridges the russian army was coming
russia raped its way right through
[ __ ] germany into berlin
even the germans after the war kept it
quiet how many women were raped and
murdered they raped murder hope the
russian army was [ __ ] absolutely
brutal
there were russian females with the
russian army some of them came back and
said this is a this is an entire army of
rapists i said uh now some of the some
of the russian women just laughed they
thought they thought they deserved it
they didn't like the germans
they didn't show any mercy for them but
they were raping children
from eight to eighty i mean just little
kids all the way up to old women
uh the
american army would find big piles of
dead women
german women
a bunch of weird [ __ ] happened that
never got released to the public like
german vermont soldiers would try to
surrender to the us army and they'd
surrender to them but then they'd go
look take all this weapons and all this
material that we have go out there and
kill some kill some more russians for us
and then come back in and
surrender they'd show them pictures of
all those [ __ ] dead german women
stuff's gonna go kill those guys so we
were sending the german army back out
there to kill russians for
what they were doing to the german women
it was they you know
so from the point of view of a german at
that time if you were in the military a
lot of them just killed themselves
when they failed i mean the whole world
was being destroyed from their point of
view it was like the end of the world
it was just
all came crashing down in a matter of a
few weeks
it was real shocking to him
yeah esther said they're still under
tornado warning due to the remnants of
hurricane ida hopefully everything's
okay over there because like i said
bad enough that it's like [ __ ]
hurricanes and floods and [ __ ] like that
then you gotta worry about [ __ ]
tornadoes okay what the [ __ ] go away
[ __ ]
what was that wow
are we getting more uh trolls yeah i'm
just you know yeah
i don't know if people weren't here
earlier i'm just kind of like i know
like we get like stupid
uh
random ass trolls
but
i know that some people that hang out
here a lot
uh have also taken to perhaps putting on
little different names and
trolling under that name and seriously
cut that [ __ ] out
it's like i don't i don't need to like
worry about it it's bad enough having to
worry about [ __ ] random ass trolls
yeah
than having to worry about like people
that hang out here all the time trying
to be funny or whatever
but you know that's kind of what that's
all about so
so can i show this now can i show
michael's thing yeah because i'm excited
okay so
we're not doing an unboxing because i
opened it yesterday
but we got this yesterday uh after we
did the stream do you want to read this
little i'm going to read this a little
better so um he says this is from
michael e by the way he was uh just here
in the chat a minute ago he's probably
still here
thanks for reviewing the hatchet series
perfect timing since kane hotter was at
a convention in detroit last week uh
bought this figure and had kane sign it
for you two hope you enjoy it my wife
wasn't too happy we weren't keeping it
well thank you very much for sending it
to us this is so rad check this out
check out how awesome this is you guys
should guys you guys look
yeah
look how awesome that is and look he has
like different little hands and stuff
yeah it was autographed by dude yeah and
like kane harder autographed it isn't
that awesome thank you so much michael i
was like so excited when i opened the
box
and look he's just like okay so here's
the picture
uh
and there's there's a cane hotter right
there
his little shirt that says give violence
a chance which i thought was very funny
oh and look if you look up here if you
look up here
next to kane hotter was that was michael
berryman's uh
thing right there so that's kind of cool
he was there as well so i guess that was
a
recent convention so thank you very much
michael that's much appreciated it's
very very cool
yeah i love show like that
but uh yeah that's a really good figure
i don't think i'd actually seen that
yesterday oh and thank you very much
esther
fifty dollars no way it was the 45th
anniversary of kerry thank you very much
oh thank you so much esther that's why
shutter just added carrie today oh okay
yeah actually they added oh you know
what they added they added carry they
added poltergeist they added the
haunting from 1963 which i was super
excited about because i love that movie
um they added a bunch of old ones which
i thought was really cool
so maybe we should maybe we should do uh
um do what you call it do a matinee on
carrie like on sunday or something
already
we i don't think we've done carrie to be
honest with you you gotta check it um
i mean i'm pretty sure we haven't
although god we've done so many movies
maybe we did
it's really hard for me to remember
it's gotten to the point now well it's
funny because i think that in the chat
um it was either on friday or last
wednesday i think it was louie and he
said um you should do a show about the
flat tire murders because they happen
here in florida
and just randomly when i was looking at
our channel we already talked about that
we did it but it wasn't its own show we
did a show about like florida crimes and
we talked about the flat tire murders in
there and i had totally forgotten that
we did that
so
yeah we already did that i don't
remember which um
which episode it was but it was a while
back
uh legend of hell house we definitely
did legend of hellhouse
that was actually
legend of hellhouse i think was maybe
only the second or third movie we
reviewed like when we first started
doing the movie reviews i'm pretty sure
i think the first one we did was the
thing
um and then legend of hellhouse was
maybe second or third and then logan's
run was one of the first ones the hunger
was one of the first ones we just got
man we just have so many that we still
have to do every time i [ __ ]
look at the list i'm just gonna like god
i can't believe we haven't done that
[ __ ] movie yet it's just like
it's hard and this is like every year
that goes by like new movies are coming
out and i gotta talk about those as well
and it's just kind of like holy crap
which version of carrie the original one
um i didn't actually what yeah i was
saying that's really the only one
although the remake wasn't that bad
it was it was actually it's all right
but now the original is the one that you
want to see
um i mean generally i don't know yeah
oracle says i mean you could go to all
the dominic noble and compare the book
to the two movie versions yeah um oh he
just put up one or actually maybe it's
just kind of on his patreon
he just put up one of um
watership down so i still have to watch
that one because i had just i even voted
in the poll because he has a poll like
before he does if you don't know who
dominic noble is he has like a channel
on youtube and he does various things
but he usually does he does a show
called lost an adaptation where he goes
like he does a deep dive like comparing
uh the movie version to the book version
and it's like really he spends like a
lot of time doing them and uh he had
done he was even doing like all the um
woody columns the [ __ ] line of which
in the world chronicles of narnia yeah
he did all those uh and [ __ ] like that
so that was like pretty funny but yeah
he does a poll and he wants to know
how many people
have just read the book how many people
have just seen the movie how many people
you know have read the book and the
movie or haven't done either one so he
knows like how much
information to impart about each thing
watership down
i read the book when i was in
elementary late elementary school or
early junior high
i think i'd seen the movie first because
you know anybody that grew up in like
the late 70s or early 80s probably saw
watership down and was like traumatized
from life because
oh it's a cartoon about bunny rabbits oh
my god mommy it's like you know what i
mean it's like it's horrifying so um you
know
and uh you know so i'm so i gotta watch
that at some point
there was the plague dogs too which i
don't think i've seen but it's on to be
and it's on my list to watch because i
want to watch that as well but i saw
watership down a bunch of times did you
ever see it yeah
yeah i saw in the theater when i was a
kid watership down
it's just like
it's one of those it's one of those
little british cartoons bunny rabbits
yeah it's good about all the scared the
[ __ ] out of me yeah i think it like i
said i think it scared the [ __ ] out of
every kid that saw it
spiritual bunny rabbits you know talking
about
the the rabbit god and rabbit jesus and
[ __ ]
remember that yeah it had it had
religious elements to it i haven't seen
it in a long time i just remember like
all the like that horrible scene with
like all the rabbits like dying and
screaming and pain and all the blood
like coming down the field and [ __ ] like
that from what i remember the rabbits
had had a religion they believed in god
but it was like a rabbit god
and stories about it about what the
about the red don't you don't remember
that
yeah i remember yeah
it's been a long time
i don't remember all the details and i
haven't read the book since i was a kid
but you know
he called him the great rabbit or
something but they they uh they
mentioned him every now and then i think
it starts off with like a
a story about the rabbit god doesn't it
i don't like like i said i haven't seen
it a long time so i don't remember it
does
i mean like i said i was i have it um
because dominic noble did a review did a
thing on it and i have it like saved
but i just haven't had a chance to watch
the story
yeah it is from what i remember and i
remember really liking the book as well
i liked there was you know i like that
in the 70s and 80s it was kind of like a
thing of
animated movies that were
uh
kind of meant for children but were also
sort of like really well uh soul
crushing
they pretended to be for children yeah
they weren't really
they're for adults
yeah
but i mean i'm not talking about heavy
metal that was obviously for adults i'm
talking about [ __ ] like that was
supposedly for children stuff like uh
for example like the brave little
toaster but then it had like these
really like horrific like all this
horrific imagery in it yeah and uh you
know kids saw it and we're like what the
[ __ ] and it like scared the crap i don't
know well you had fire and ice and you
had a bunch of them that
they had one i think was called wizards
um
yeah remember wizards
uh we yeah
then they had one of the french one
about the human about the about the the
aliens that captured all the humans and
kept them as pets
what was that called
what you doing um i'm just i'm typing
maybe you guys might remember which one
it was called
fantastic voyage no
was it called fantastic voyage i think
it might have been called fantastic
voyage i don't remember that one so good
yeah that's about a guy and he's being
he's born and raised as a pet to these
aliens fantastic planet fantastic planet
that's what it was called yeah that was
weird i got to see that one again i
haven't seen that in a long time that
was another one that scared me as a kid
it was it was french
yeah it was any english
there was a german one called fella day
yeah about the cats about the cats
pretty sure that wasn't really uh for
kids either was that a serial killer
wasn't it serious i think yeah i think
it was and there was like cat sex and
all kind of gore and
[ __ ] like that yeah and the humane
society was killing all the cats and
that was freaking out like the cat
concentration camp yeah it was like it
was [ __ ] up
um
i was gonna say too i might have brought
this up before
uh and i remember writing a like hey you
knocked spock over
he's gonna kick your ass he's
you knocked spock over he's gonna man
that's the ghost man
no that was you
he's gonna get his agonizer out and [ __ ]
you up while you're not looking mr ross
he's gonna hand me your agony your
agonizer please he's gonna sneak up
behind it i'm not gonna say a damn word
he's gonna sneak up on it he's gonna go
how funny would that be but yeah so i
had written a blog post about this when
i was a kid
i saw this cartoon that was like jack
and the beanstalk right
but it was like super [ __ ] trippy
there was like a little mechanical witch
in it and madame hecuba that was like a
giant that had
boxer shorts with hearts on it whose
name was tulip yeah it was tulip and it
had like music in it you know what i
mean and it's like so the witch was
keeping this little princess with pointy
hair was keeping her prisoner but was
keeping her like drugged up and was like
um she was supposed to marry the giant
and like the princess was all yeah
supposed to have because she was all
like drugged up and everything
and it had some like really freaky
like sequences in it like especially the
one part like at the wedding at the end
like the witch
she had like cut out all these paper
people like to be guests at the wedding
because nobody else lived on this like
cloud city place whatever it was and
then she like animated them and it was
just like this really creepy song and it
was just like this really cool creepy um
cartoon and i saw it when i was a kid on
cable probably like in
i don't know 1979 1980 something like
that and then i didn't see it for a
really long time and then i thought
um
you know since i didn't see it for a
long time and i kept like asking people
about it hey do you ever see this like
jack and the beanstalk and it was like
this crazy with a little mechanical
witch and they were like what the [ __ ]
what are you talking about and so for a
while i thought maybe i just dreamed it
um then but then i ended up coming
across it on youtube and actually i
didn't know this when i was growing up
but it was actually japanese it was like
a um it was a japanese version of jack
and the beanstalk and they were trying
to make something that was sort of like
approximating a disney movie um but of
course since it was japan it came out
kind of like strange but in a good way
because i but i just like really really
liked it and so i rewatched it again
like recently and i'm just like yep
that's just as weird as i remembered
also if you guys haven't seen another
animated movie called rock and roll i
think i probably brought that one up too
that's canadian i believe
um
i think nelvonna made it was the name of
the studio and that one was actually
really really awesome and it even had
like great [ __ ] music like it had
[ __ ] debbie harry and iggy pop and
lou reed and cheap trick and
[ __ ] like that but it was just like it
was like a post-apocalyptic like it was
a bunch of like people that had evolved
from rats
but it was about but it wasn't really
about that it was about like a rock band
and then it was about this
rock star named mock the magic man
and he was like
trying to find um
the this a person with a voice that
would open up like a dimension
like open up a door to another dimension
like an evil dimension so he could have
all the power on earth or something but
that's also really good and that might
be on youtube too because i think i
watched that too not too long ago for
free
sandra said i loved the last unicorn as
a child yeah i liked that too that was
like
i remember that being kind of messed up
too was it not didn't didn't mia pharaoh
do the voice of the unicorn am i
remembering that wrong
i'm pretty sure that was mia farrow's
voice
i remember something kind of [ __ ] up
happening in that but i can't remember
what it was
the last unicorn
and i think that was from a book because
i think i read the book as well like
when i was a kid
i'm trying to
another one that i really liked from
back then was um
the secret of nim
about the mice and the the mice and like
the super intelligent rats
and that and the rats were like helping
the little mouse like help like move her
little house so that the plow didn't
kill her and her family i don't remember
that one yeah that was um
what's his [ __ ] name someone i'm sure
somebody in the comments knows don bluth
i think that was don bluth and i read
the book too but the book is called mrs
frisbie and they're
rats of them but that was like a good
story too and i think that's actually on
youtube
for free
like you know how youtube has movies and
you can watch movies for free like on
there um yeah i think it's on there not
like people that have just uploaded it
but it's just on there like officially
you know what i'm saying
um yeah dj maniac said i saw it on night
flight when i was a kid
which one
uh fantastic planet
yeah maybe
all right yeah so i don't remember if i
ever saw that one although now now i'm
kind of like curious about it
because now i kind of want to see it to
see if i've seen it before i've probably
seen it but it was in english you said
it's not it wasn't it what
fantastic planet it was in english but i
think it was dubbed into english
i mean you couldn't tell
it was animated yeah
i think it was originally in french
but then there's the english versions of
it interesting it was good
very two-dimensional it's like cutouts
real odd [ __ ] oh yeah cool it kind of
looked like
the animated sequences from um
um
what was that british
what was that british
comedy series that had all those
what monty python monty python yeah man
remember monty python had these little
animated sequences between skits weird
[ __ ] it looked like that
that's how i remembered it i see what
you're saying yeah
fantastic planet
okay well that's what i'm gonna have to
write that down because now i kind of
want to yeah
i might have seen it i just don't
remember i'm gonna put that over there
because it's like kind of under my
whatever so i'm going to write that
right over here because otherwise i'll
forget because everybody just gives me
good recommendations
says yeah fantastic planet i have a copy
on vhs
wow yeah
yeah watership down that's how we kind
of got it started talking about yeah
talking about hugo said fantastic planet
is in french yeah but i saw
you you saw a dubbed angel i saw it
dubbed english version yeah yeah in
english
i'm trying to think of like some other
some other good [ __ ] from back then
70s had a lot of good animated stuff
it did and the 80s did too like early
80s i was telling them about that weird
ass um
jack and the beanstalk
that i saw when i was a kid that i found
out much later was japanese but i didn't
realize because that was also dubbed
into english if you guys haven't seen um
fire and ice you want to check that out
kind of like a conan type
story
that one and the and the original um
um
lord of the rings
not the the animated lord of the year
it's pretty good i liked you know what i
liked the animated hobbit better than i
liked the animated lord of the rings is
that weird to say i liked them both oh
they were different at art styles
yeah rings was kind of like fire and ice
it was i think rotoscope it was done
over actually film
looked pretty cool um
you know just
see what i was going to say i was going
to say something about one of them
fire and ice is pretty good because it
was kind of like a conan story but
conan was a was a prop was was an owned
property so they couldn't use that
they're like well we need another
muscle-bound barbarian fellow we just
can't call them that well they had two
remember yeah it was that well
what was his name
wolf killer i think it was his name yeah
yeah was his name wolf killer we just
watched that not too long because we did
a review of it yeah it was kind of like
conan the thing is is that
in there's a bunch of documentaries on
that blu-ray that that that i think it
was louis that sent that to me i don't
remember who sent it to me then you guys
sent us so many stuff i can't keep it i
can't keep it straight who's that what
but um
in the in the
documentaries about it
they say they tell you what the original
script was and i wish they would have
gone with the original script
where it turned out that wolf killer was
actually the dad of the bad guy
yeah i think a lot more i think we
talked about that when we when we did
the review of it it should not have how
that made how that would have tied the
story together it was
yeah it tied the story together and it
was like on a star wars level of you
know what i mean no i am your father
it's like that kind of no yeah it's like
you find out where these the will
killers trying to kill this dude needs
his son you know because
it was kind of like he's an abomination
son you know because there's i guess
there was
and and then there was some like incest
going on between his son and and the mom
the baby mama
this is some weird [ __ ] it's kind of
like that's some dirty dirty family well
kind of
kind of like in in uh
an excalibur you know what was his name
mordred
yeah mordred and his mom
what was the mom's name it was uh
[ __ ]
arthur's uh
arthur's sister
she ended up turning into morgan lafaye
was it morgan no no no wasn't it i might
have been
i'm like i'm so sleepy it's like i can't
even my brain is like really sluggish
she ended up becoming a sorceress
man i wish i could be a sorceress that'd
be so rad lily says jenny you look
gorgeous by the way thank you you have
perfect skin thank you very much it's
not though i just put like makeup over
it
[Laughter]
yeah that's that's that's one thing i
got lucky with
uh derwent says when the wind blows was
definitely not for kids that is um
another one that's on my list that i'm
gonna do on my flickr's affair show
because i had not heard of that one
until i was doing the research for
threads
uh you know that nuclear war thing and a
bunch of people in the comments like
when i was reading like about threads
they were talking about when the wind
blows and that's like an animated
nuclear war
type of uh type of thing like this is
what happens with the [ __ ]
cause man
i don't know is it is it a bigger bummer
than threads cause man threads is like
that was one of the most depressing
[ __ ] things i've ever seen like you
know what i mean seriously that was a
really really depressing movie way worse
than what was the one that they had over
here the day after
do you remember that one came out in 83
sounds familiar it was just like showing
everybody they showed it on network tv
but it was just kind of like they were
trying to show everybody like what it
would be like if there was like really a
nuclear war
and um i remember everybody was talking
about it in school the next day i think
i was in
eighth grade ninth grade no
no i was only in third or fourth grade
at that point
um yeah so
everybody was talking about the next day
and it's like we're talking about how
[ __ ] up it was but then
um people were like yeah that's nothing
watch the british one threads and it's
like i watched it and wow that's way
worse
holy crap
that was really um
yeah you really like
the whole nuclear war
thing man was a uh
i mean
of course you don't nobody wants a
nuclear war but there there was a lot of
[ __ ] psychological operations going
on a read a really good book
called the future of warfare
and it was written by a guy who is a
damn
big [ __ ] uh arms dealer worked for
raytheon and
um
some of the companies that made all the
nuclear weapons
and he ended up working for jane's
defense weekly and that's where the
nations buy their weapons through jane's
defense so you know they [ __ ]
raytheon [ __ ] and
mcdonald douglas ads all through it
it was some funny [ __ ]
that the that the us military did the
cia
they hyped up
they knew that the soviets
did not
have very much money
so when it came to nuclear research they
had just enough money to build their
weapons and
get their military built up but they
didn't really have the money to spend on
[ __ ] like
damage analysis and research and what
how long the fallout lasts and
what would be the ecological you know
damage of having a nuclear exchange
they knew that they were getting it from
us they had spies in our system sending
the data back
so everything that we said we
exaggerated by about 10 times
and the idea was to [ __ ] feed the
soviets
a
bad or
unrealistic
image of what a nuclear war would have
actually done and then what a nuclear
war would have actually looked like how
many how many weapons would have been
exchanged and everything before
before politics would have took over you
know
now at certain times you know i think
back in the 60s you know the doctor
strangelove era they probably just would
have [ __ ] wiped each other out
but by the time the 70s and the 80s
rolled around
neither side wanted that fight
so we were psyching the russians out
with all these [ __ ]
doomsday scenarios
and we did it by making movies and [ __ ]
like that
and the american public bought it you
could use
we were using the american public to
scare the [ __ ] out of the russians
the chances are there even if a nuclear
warhead had happened
by the time the 70s had rolled around it
would have only probably been a couple
of them and
man we were setting off nuclear weapons
all the time above ground it didn't have
a huge impact
yeah some people died but
not enough to make a difference in the
long in in the big
in the big uh picture of things i think
they set off a couple hundred of those
nuclear weapons above ground by the time
they banned
nuclear testing above ground
it wouldn't have made a big difference
it's funny
well you know still not good and they
still made it yeah still made movies
well yeah you know they were doing
things like they were making that they
were making the
the bombs a lot smaller they're making
them tactical
and there's a lot of secrets a lot of
nuclear secrets one of the big nuclear
secrets you know this guy from jane's
defense talked about it is how
ineffective they were
i mean
hiroshima and nagasaki were made out of
wooden paper
and bombed both of them
and within a few weeks they were
both those cities were functioning
cities again a couple weeks later it
didn't do that much damage
had you would uh
had you dropped that on a stone city
somewhere in europe it would it would
have done a fraction of the damage that
you saw
it just
all the damage was concentrated at
around ground zero everything else was
just blast damage
and it wasn't that impressive but
psychologically it was very impressive
you know what i mean it was
just regular conventional bombing
missions were worse much worse because
it was spread out over a larger area
they were secretly working on [ __ ] like
cluster munitions
mervs
and uh wet nuclear clustered
munitions that drop off many warheads in
an area so you can get into every little
nook and cranny but still
you're destroying a city it's mostly
civilians what the [ __ ] would you want
to do that for
you know what i mean you don't really
win a war that way because you're an
[ __ ] yeah
it was world war ii thinking
you know
and we weren't bombing cities in world
war ii to win the war anyway they were
trying to find factories
because we'd already bombed the
factories they took the factories apart
moved them into people's houses and
people were working at home to make
weaponry
you know
and or they were also flying up so high
you could hit a factory anyway they all
just [ __ ] spill into the [ __ ]
neighborhoods anyway so
yeah you could drop a nuclear bomb in
there and [ __ ] maybe destroy a
factory but that's because they didn't
have guidance you know it went over this
laser guided and gps guided so much
better you know
you could hit it who bombs away we don't
even know don't know where it's hidden
we don't know where we're aiming at
sorry yeah
yeah
carpet bomb whatever carpet bombing
and nuclear bombs nuclear weapons were
trying to compensate for lack of
accuracy that's really all it was well
it only has to be close
you know if it lands within a couple of
miles it'll it'll destroy the factory
yeah close enough yeah
but that's pretty [ __ ] up you know
convent
it's part of conventional warfare and
conventional warfare doesn't achieve
anything really
just look at afghanistan nothing was
achieved
yeah four throwdown said uh yeah the
idea that both sides would just fire off
everything was rather unrealistic yeah
it wouldn't have happened
remember i and i actually i think i put
this movie in uh the poll for next week
uh war games remember that one with uh
what's his name matthew broderick where
he was like a computer hacker or
something how they hacked into norad
yeah and then it accidentally
accidentally started off world war three
yeah as one does with her [ __ ] apple
2e but you know we were like worried
about that [ __ ] back then
the most likely scenario was an accident
in other words launching something off
by accident
yeah that was more likely which is kind
of what this was right
and
if you just accidentally launched one
and it landed somewhere in the united
states
the u.s would probably accept that that
it was accident because it was on
purpose they would have sent a bunch of
them yeah
they probably wouldn't have responded
they would have won a bunch of sanctions
and
reparations and you have to [ __ ] sign
all kinds of treaties
another likely one is that maybe they
probably would have used a nuclear
weapon on something like an aircraft
battle carrier group something like that
out in the ocean
you can get away with that
yeah because that's a military target
you know your aircraft or carrier was
over here [ __ ] your aircraft carrier
boom [ __ ] your aircraft carrier now what
are you going to do
well that's a big difference
between
you know between launching one on this
on a city
you know what i mean your navy's like
yeah we weren't supposed to be there
let's not launch on them because then
they'll launch on us okay you got us we
weren't supposed to be there
that's probably what would happen fair
enough fair enough
don't get don't bring your aircraft
carrier over here we'll do it again that
kind of [ __ ]
it will get more of the same it would
have been what they called a limited
exchange
they would have purposely
shot at [ __ ] where it wasn't worth it to
respond to because you know what i mean
both sides were trying to de-escalate
they didn't want it to escalate
to where you're striking cities in
people's homes people in people's
homelands and blowing up a city doesn't
achieve much it's not a military target
it just makes them madder ask the
british
the germans bombed london and the
british what happened the british got
pissed off that's all they got british
got pissed off they fought harder
well yeah i mean that's all they have
it's like hey that's our cities you're
[ __ ] yeah
because you know we got to live there
and stuff yeah you're dropping them
things on [ __ ] innocent women and
children
that was a big mistake that the germans
did they should have never
they should have left england alone
france i can understand but there was no
reason to even [ __ ] with england england
would have really gotten involved i
don't think
if it wasn't for that
bomb in london
yeah well but they just weren't thinking
clearly they were thinking too hard
that's kind of too much that's kind of
what i don't know well i don't even know
if it was that well like you said you
would we're kind of going back to what
you were saying before about them being
on like all these [ __ ] drugs and
everything not at that point of the war
that that was early in the war
although i do kind of feel like well i
think that's what i was going to say
like a long time ago that i forgot about
when we were talking about that about
hitler being all those drugs and stuff
and i was gonna say that it was almost
kind of like more acceptable back then
to be on a bunch of that stuff because a
lot of that [ __ ] like you know uppers
and stuff like that were legal right and
they you know what i mean so a lot of
people were taking them yeah they
weren't any stigma about drugs so there
wasn't any stigma about it and honestly
like the more i read about that time
period i'm like how do those people live
even as long as they lived [ __ ] man i
have like a couple too many drinks and i
gotta sleep for two days i don't like
understand how people can be like 50
years old and be like okay here's the
uppers and now here's the downers and
there he's this and that and he's holy
crap man
i just i don't understand how they can
[ __ ] they must have like a much more
hearty constitution than i have that's
for sure
in the first half of the 1900s if it
felt good that it was good
if you took a drug and it made you feel
good then [ __ ] that must be good for you
that's just the thinking at a time
the idea that it could catch up to you
they didn't really think of it that way
yeah they didn't really seem to did they
no
that's that's interesting and that's
probably why just because well it can't
be bad it's making me feel awesome yeah
you know there's no way this could just
be building up in my system and then
just like have diminishing returns and
be like [ __ ] up all my organs well it
was like in the 70s with arnold and all
those guys down at gold gym i mean
they're [ __ ] popping out of our pills
like there's no tomorrow and doing doing
anabolic steroids and eating and getting
huge how could this not be healthy
yeah you know look how strong i am
how could that not be healthy you know
and they lived a long time they're still
alive a lot of them
yeah there's a lot of stress on your
heart your internal organs you know yeah
and like i said it wasn't really
anything they do you know and it's kind
of like
i don't really think that no they didn't
really seem to understand like
moderation
you know what i mean or it wasn't like a
widespread
type of like if you know if it makes you
feel good or if a little bit of it is
good for you then obviously more of it
is even better
and it just really did seem that that
seemed like a like kind of a mindset
that a lot of people had all right well
the thing with steroids
it made sense if you were there at the
time
they were injecting vitamins
first
and injecting vitamins was the thing out
of the cattle industry and they would
inject vitamins and i don't remember
which one it was
in vitamin d i think
you get that from the sun don't you
vitamin i remember which vitamin it was
they'd inject a bunch of these vitamins
and they reported that they got a little
bit bigger
prototypes of steroids came
and they would inject some of those
but they didn't get any bigger
they didn't see a big difference between
vitamins and steroids
so then they took those steroids and
[ __ ] amped them up and increased the
dosage by about 50 times and then they
noticed a difference
okay
well that 50 times dosage right is now a
normal street dose they didn't know what
the street dosage was
okay
so they go well if the normal dose was
one but taking it to 50 brought results
[ __ ] it let's take it to 500.
and those dudes got [ __ ] huge all
right but it killed them eventually
you know
burn out your heart valves depending on
what which one it was and for how long
they were doing it and what they were
doing and yeah i mean we're just little
meat sacks it's like you know our [ __ ]
can only take so much
stress and pressure you know everybody
has a breaking point yeah you can't just
like keep pouring [ __ ] in there like
forever and expect to and there are
genetic differences well yeah obviously
yeah not everybody's the same
if you think everybody's the same you're
[ __ ] tripping you just believe in
what your mom told you
[Laughter]
yeah you're you're pretty honey that's
what your mom said [ __ ] another gent
if you look at those pro bodybuilders
first of all their diets are perfect
their [ __ ] workouts are very hard
they're taking a [ __ ] ton of drugs that
are very [ __ ] good quality there's
lots of them
and if the average person were to take
that regime they wouldn't end up looking
like those dudes
because those dudes also happen to have
fantastic genetics that respond well to
those drugs
other people don't respond those that
well to those drugs
some people that
[ __ ] don't respond at all wouldn't
respond at all to those drugs and you
know like a little bit that's it
other people it could kill
so there's an element of well that's
what i mean that's why medicine in a lot
of ways is really complicated and that's
why there's like this this big thing
about
all these different kind of drugs and
why they have to go through all these
different kind of tests and it's like
even when they do go through all these
tests and they release them there's all
this big long thing it's like hey you
might have this side effect or that side
effect because they don't know they
don't know they can't test it on
everybody and everybody is genetically a
little bit different so you never know
like how that person's gonna react to it
one person it might be awesome and
another person it might not work so good
another person it might like cause
really really bad side effects that's
what those [ __ ] quarterly drug tests
are all about
they go in there and look at your blood
work and see how you respond into all
that stuff
if anything looks wrong they have to
change the dosage or even take you off
yeah it's like anybody that's on any
kind of like long-term medication
um you know they they have to be under
like a doctor's supervision because you
have to
and then some drugs stop working or stop
being effective after a certain time and
they have to like change it out change
the dose or do whatever
so
you know like i said it's complicated
and not everyone's the same so
the poster boy of the 70s of course was
arnold schwarzenegger
lou ferrigno too lou lou looked [ __ ]
great all right
that was back in the golden era
there was other ones too you know
[ __ ] um
some of them were shorter or some of
them were taller their frames are a
little bit different
but the one i think everybody ended up
liking was arnold and it's just because
he's kind of like
the total package
but a lot of what you're seeing there is
genetics
you know what i mean i could take what
he take and do what he did at the age he
did and i wouldn't come out that way
you know it was his height
the type of frame that he had
and just the way he responded to those
drugs he looked good and he had a
character [ __ ] was a smart ass
he was funny
and he was a [ __ ] too arnold
schwarzenegger was a [ __ ] he was stuck
up snotty but everybody liked him he was
the um
women that dated him said that he had an
addictive quality to him it's like if
you were around him you didn't want to
leave him because he was just constantly
entertaining
now
he didn't age that well you know a lot
of it had to do with the drug abuse at
an early age you know
it was abuse if you look at his physique
how big he was
in the 70s
i mean at the age of [ __ ] 20
something i mean he was just [ __ ]
huge
you know
when you see him in conan and in
terminator he'd actually lost a lot of
size he he was small compared to the way
he used to look
he was [ __ ] big
but he wasn't tall but i'm just saying
you know his proportions he very big
not as big as what you could get today
though some of those dudes are [ __ ]
that's the thing
arnold came from the golden era where
the where aesthetics mattered you had to
look good
the proportions had to be right they had
to be classic proportions
some of these guys now man they're 100
pounds even 100 pounds heavier but they
just look [ __ ] up they just look like
a big ass [ __ ] barn door there's just
nothing aesthetically pleasing about it
you know
you can get to be where it's just too
goddamn much
well that's kind of and we talked about
this when we did the history of
bodybuilding show where i kind of feel
like maybe less so nowadays but i kind
of feel like remember in the 90s when
there was really kind of this
um there was kind of a trend in
bodybuilding for everybody just wanting
to get as big as possible yeah and you
really got these dudes and they were
just and they were just like yeah that's
what i said and it was like and they
just looked like these monstrous freaks
of nature with like veins poking out
everywhere and they were just a big
misshapen they look like
marvel villains or something yeah and
the the the one the main one
of what she's talking about is named
ronnie coleman and he was a cop
ronnie was the best looking of them
but still he was just he i'm not gonna
say that ronnie coleman was an ugly dude
not saying that he didn't have
he didn't have classic aesthetics to me
he looked too big
he's very unhealthy he [ __ ] his
skeleton up and everything but
ronnie coleman is about the peak you
can't get any bigger than that and you
don't want to be you don't want to be as
big as ronnie coleman
well it's just kind of like it's just
kind of like when there was a trend
particularly i guess in the 80s and 90s
in porn yeah for women to just have
these ridiculous like beach ball sized
tits it gets the performer's diminishing
returns yeah well it gets to a point
where it's just it's not really sexy and
it just looks freakish and because when
i see a woman like that all i can think
of was like her poor back yeah like she
can't sleep on her stomach it's like
every like nothing no clothes fit it
just seems like yeah those girls though
are kind of like the female equivalent
of [ __ ]
open class bodybuilders though well yeah
that's why
they got boob greed it's a fetish they
[ __ ] love it yeah the same thing with
those open class bodybuilders they love
that [ __ ] it's like an addiction to them
it's it's like body dysmorphia
yeah
it's pretty much the similar kind of
thing for me
that's about it right there you don't
want to be any bigger than that
well because that still looks natural to
some degree yeah
that's impossible natural
but it's aesthetic yeah it has you know
it's aesthetically pleasing
that looks within
within reason you know what i mean
yeah it's not like you don't look like a
you know like a monster right yeah
you look like a car too you're a cartoon
man you know like like a cartoon conan
but you know i don't think there's
anything wrong with that now is that
healthy
uh no
no not to maintain that
all year round
no
uh but you can come close
camp guy is asking what you think about
lee haney uh lee haney uh man it sounds
familiar i can't put a face to the
bodybuilder yet yeah i know i know that
name i think we talked about him on that
i'd have to go look at him
what what in particular
we want me to judge him
[Laughter]
sounds familiar you'll have to like look
it up i guess there's so many good ones
that's the thing there are a lot of good
ones
i mean um franco franco colombo the i
liked the 70s classics
um for the most part
i liked the 70s golden era aesthetics
you know a lot of v taper vacuum pose
[ __ ] good delts [ __ ]
good muscle insertions
i'm you're not talking about a 300 pound
man you're not that big you know what i
mean it depends on how tall he is but
you know
i'm i'm taller than franco colombo by a
couple inches i mean franco colombo was
like one rogan tall all right
um
in a way though franco sometimes was too
big for his
for his size i mean sometimes he looked
a little short squat and bulky
other times he looked better depending
on how much weight he had on him at the
time
because franco was
bigger than that
and only like uh
five three maybe
by four so my height yeah because i'm
five foot three yeah and
he's in conan he's the [ __ ] tribal
guy who's running and [ __ ] he's the
first guy you see who runs out of the
woods and sees conan's village guys all
the tattoos on him yeah that's franco
colombo
yeah i remember that name because like i
said when we did that show i remember
like looking up a bunch of photos and
stuff too
he died a few years back
died of heart attacks women
he's from sardinia
sandra said do any of the girls here
uh find arnold uh arnold schwarzenegger
attractive somehow i find him completely
unappealing even when he was young i do
not find him particularly attractive now
we talked about that yeah
who's saying who's asking this sandra
snyder okay
even arnold here's the funny thing about
arnold
arnold had a very
in his prime had a very magnetic
character
his character has not aged too well
he said a lot of [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] over
the years he pissed a lot of other
bodybuilders off
he changed a lot hollywood changed him i
think being a politician changed him
um
for me arnold will always be a guy in
the 70s and the 80s that's the arnie
that i know you know that that that was
that was ultimate arnie
even arnie in hit he
arnie was never sexy even arnie knew
that
yeah he's definitely does not have any
sex appeal no
and arnold schwarzenegger knew that
yeah
he didn't want to do romantic roles he
thought he he
he felt very goofy he he
he kind of um felt that he was a little
um
like a fish out of water when it came to
sexy roles that's not who he was
um
he's also not
real serious like in in the terminator
roles and conan he comes across being
real serious that's not who he is
if you talk to guys who came up with him
uh who were friends of his from early on
he was a goofball
oh yeah that definitely comes across
he's just a [ __ ] goofball
a constantly joking constantly [ __ ]
talk of [ __ ] constantly laughing
constantly teasing somebody else talking
[ __ ] about other people constant
goofball
he was never serious he's still not
serious
i kind of wonder about though i wonder
if that is if i wonder if that is just
like his personality just in general or
is it like does it stem from some kind
of insecurity of some kind
i wonder just wondering i don't know if
that's no i don't think he's insecure at
all i don't know the dude so i don't
really know
no he's not insecure at all he's he was
an ex-tanker from german army uh or it
might have been austrian army it was
might have been the austrian army
so he had a military career he ran away
uh from the military went awol to do a
[ __ ] posing competition he was a
bodybuilder at that time but he didn't
that totally sounds like something yeah
yeah
i would go to this i got to go to the
show and they ah no you got duty no [ __ ]
this
he got busted for that but he he
you know he got honorable discharge he
did his time
um he was no he was a very confident guy
he was evidently um
uh popular with women he um
had no problem with women uh
they flocked to him but
he said he never really felt like a sexy
guy and evidently he wasn't very good at
a sexy role so he was not like that for
some reason yeah he's kind of
uncomfortable with that
yeah and then
it shows yeah he was not a very open guy
he was kind of
i think that's what it is he comes
across as just very
mechanical well yeah that's what i'm
saying that's why i said i wondered if
it's stem from insecurity because a lot
of this the way that he acts you know
being out you know being boisterous and
funny and pranking and stuff like that a
lot of that comes across as like defense
mechanisms because you don't want to
like let people in or you don't want to
like let people see any kind of
vulnerability that's what i meant
and i think that in a lot of ways a lot
of sexiness
comes from someone that is willing to be
open and vulnerable to a degree
so somebody that's very closed off and
is just kind of like keeping people at
arm's length by being just like this
over-the-top like funny goofball clown
type of person um is not going to have
any sex appeal which is why like a lot
of comedians for example
don't really have a lot of sex appeal
because
you know some of them do i'm not saying
all of them but a lot of them don't and
it's for that reason because you know
that
their sense of humor is a defense
mechanism
you know because they have other
problems you know what you know what i
mean yeah a lot of pro bodybuilders
don't
have unusual personalities
um
they don't have much of a social life
uh
well that takes up a lot of yeah they
are in a gym all the time working out
and this they go to the gym like we
would go to the club or a bar yeah it's
just it's a scene you know yeah they're
hanging out in there [ __ ] talking and
this and that and they work out and then
they drink some [ __ ] and they hang
around they drink some [ __ ] protein
shakes then they wait for their buddy to
show up and then he works out and talks
so they're hanging out in the gym
talking [ __ ] but they don't have much of
a social life
it's hanging out in that scene
um
and then they're health food fanatics so
they don't really party that much not
some of them do so it seems like talk
about the pros i mean they wouldn't
really be that fun to hang around i
don't think they are because they can't
like just like let loose they're like no
i can't eat that i have to eat this raw
egg shake or whatever the [ __ ] it is
the for the pros are constantly in
competition with each other
constantly looking at each other and
seeing who's getting bigger than who
because they're trying to figure out can
i beat him in the 90 days to the show so
they're constantly you know they [ __ ]
around with each other but they're just
totally focused on that [ __ ] like
they're astronauts or something yeah
they're like that kind of a person
they're they're they're
gonna be totally [ __ ] dedicated to
that [ __ ] now gym rats that's different
they're not pros
you know what i mean they have a life
outside that they they work out a couple
times a week and then they [ __ ] do
their [ __ ] and they have they party
so that's not quite the same thing the
pros are obsessed
yeah just like those dudes that ride
their damn bicycles those pros are also
obsessed they don't really have much of
it so like i said to get it to get um
top level to be a pro in those types of
fields you really have to kind of
dedicate your whole entire life to it
yeah you know it's particularly like i
said if you what anything due to
bodybuilding gymnastics anything like
that you pretty much have to like
dedicate your whole entire life to like
your you know your [ __ ] diet and your
workout your [ __ ] everything now in
the case of arnie he ended up becoming
an actor
so he probably wasn't acting that way
um
when he was an actor he was probably
living it up
but when he was a pro bodybuilder no he
was [ __ ] totally dedicated to that
[ __ ]
in terms of guys who had great physiques
who probably had what you would call
sexiness
and who were popular with women and
we're kind of more of like a full
package i want to say i don't want to i
don't want to be little pro bodybuilders
i don't want to belittle arnie he was
great at what he did
arnie wasn't 100 of the full package all
the time
all right
he had things that he was lacking art
artistic ability was one of them he
wasn't very artistic
on the other hand the guy who had the
full package would have been stallone
stallone was an artist he could act he
had good taste in things he could write
he could write he could write movies
they said that he was he was real fun to
hang out with he partied
um he trained with a lot of the same
guys that aren't with arnie and the
other guys in the same scene at gold's
gym
and you know for rambo three by the time
that happened he was [ __ ] he was in
good shape
but stallone was always a person
yeah that well that's exactly what i was
going to say he always came across as
like a real
person whereas i'm not saying arnold
schwarzenegger is not a real person i'm
just saying he always comes across
as though he's a little robotic or he's
keeping people at arm's length
you know with his with his facade this
personality this wall he's put up
stallone was the kind of guy that could
[ __ ] he could be he could be the
tough guy he could play that role in a
movie he could be tough they say he's
alpha as [ __ ] when he shows up he's an
old guy now in great shape and they say
he shows up to this to the bars where
all these [ __ ] other guys are hanging
out muscle guys like him and they're
just like whoa it's like he's like he's
not that big he's you know he's a little
bit taller than me in terms of height
wise but he's kind of like the the old
alpha of alphas comes in there and he's
just like at the center of attention
between all these [ __ ] dudes who just
looking worshiping [ __ ]
muscle dudes and [ __ ] cops and
soldiers and [ __ ] you know
and um
but they say that uh they say that that
stallone
um understood concepts like [ __ ]
charm and romance and [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean and uh
wooing women and even though and like i
said i mean i don't really find
sylvester stallone any more physically
attractive than uh arnold schwarzenegger
i'm just you know i'm saying that but
sylvester stallone always struck me as
like if i had to hang out with one of
them i would hang out with stallone
because he always seemed like he'd be
more of a real person very much so from
what i've heard you know like i've never
met either one of them but it's just all
from people who know him and things that
i could put together about him
if he wanted to hang out and [ __ ]
have a good time at the club it'd be
with stallone
honestly in a lot of ways like it's you
know if you're talking about like
bodybuilding type or you know that type
of look um honestly i think like the
rock is like sexier because well because
he has like a personality yeah and he's
also kind of a dork and he's like kind
of like enthusiastic about stuff and
it's like that's super cute that's a
different generation now what was
talking about yeah the golden era guys
right now it'd be the rock jason statham
um
who's the dude that played aquaman jason
momoa yeah momoa he seems pretty cool um
i think state them [ __ ] is cool
adam all i'd probably say the rock the
rock has a very positive personality
um his aesthetics are good
um
and then uh
there's um oh what's his name can look
good too [ __ ] a dude who played
bronson um
tom hardy tom hardy can [ __ ] get
pretty big too he's pretty foxy yeah
now
i like his work but they say he that
he's just [ __ ] you just can't stand
to be around him [ __ ] and and it kind
of
it looks like it might be true but
that's i'm just going by one on other
they say vid diesel is a [ __ ] dick
really yeah they say vin diesel just
although you know what honestly that
doesn't surprise me he kind of comes
across like that i don't know i don't
know him but i say he's a dick i don't
know if it's true
but you know
they're like oh no be glad you're not
around that dude
[Laughter]
like i said i don't know these people in
person but just i mean to an extent you
can kind of tell what people would be
like yeah um you know if you see them in
the public eye a lot like their
personality is at least gonna leak
through partially you would think
um you know because they can't you can't
keep a clamp down forever but yeah vin
diesel does kind of seem like
well he kind of i i'm not going to say
it it's going to like
into steven seagal territory but i kind
of feel like maybe he takes himself a
little bit too seriously
and um people that take themselves too
seriously are just like no fun to hang
around ever
so like i said that's why that's why
nobody likes who was it that sent me the
video
um one of y'all sent me a video on
facebook
about somebody had made a video about
why steven seagal was like the biggest
[ __ ] in hollywood and like why nobody
wanted to work with him and it had like
all the stories about that people had
told them about it like some of them i
knew but some of them i didn't know and
it was just like super funny i liked
that somebody had done like a super cut
of like all the dick all the dick moves
that he pulled over the years it's like
i don't know i just like i don't want
the whole entire show to devolve into
like steven seagal [ __ ] again but it's
just kind of like because we always kind
of end up
[Music]
sergeant rocket system makes me chuckle
he looks like a melting candle
but
actually during um rambo the fight
continues he obviously when he looked
the worst
you could tell he was [ __ ] around the
hgh his [ __ ] his face really was
[ __ ] up yeah his face is uh kind of
weird he's got it fixed though
and that's because for a while there
people thought that you didn't need
anabolic steroids
that you could use human growth
hormone and yeah you can get big on
human growth hormone but you'll know
your nose and your lips will get big too
which maybe is not what you want it
should start yeah so you know they had
to fix that
don't do hgh it's no no
if people thought that maybe that might
be an easy way out
less stress on your heart
no hgh see no such thing as an easy fix
it's like yeah it'll be good for the
rest of your body but it's going to make
your face look all [ __ ] up yeah now
you're gonna look like this big giant
like this you have this big huge
schnauze like a [ __ ]
don't
do look like a gnome
don't do steroids
i will never tell you to do steroids
unless you know what you're doing but no
do not steroids all right [ __ ]
not without [ __ ] serious supervision
and a serious [ __ ] head check about
what that does
what the limits are and what it does to
you long term
if you're a young guy unless there's
something wrong with you you shouldn't
need any of those antibiotic steroids
unless for some reason you want to
become a barn door or you want to get
and if you do that's on you yeah maybe
that's what you're going for which yeah
fair enough i'm not judging like i said
um hrt
hormone replacement therapy or trt
yeah
after when you know after
35 if you're having problems recovering
that's one of the things you might want
to do to keep some of the [ __ ] fat
off you
um
keep your metabolism running good keep
you leaner
and
from everything it looks like it can
extend life just by
keeping you thinner all right
well not thinner just keeping you from
becoming obese
okay
but you always want to work out
past the age of 35. if not you're gonna
get fat you're going to get skinny fat
too
um
anabolics
you want to do as little as you possibly
can as late as you possibly can
there's as late as you put like 50s 60s
70s if it's done right
it can strengthen you
uh so at least you'll die strong you may
not you're gonna die but you might die
in better condition might buy you a few
more years
if you abuse that [ __ ] early on you
can't [ __ ] with it later on because
you're already ravaged by it
so that's the thing
that's what happened to those dudes from
the golden era
they were popping in of our pills just
like candy by the time they were 16 17
years old they're eating that [ __ ] their
livers they [ __ ] your liver up
you know
and then all that [ __ ] muscle on
there's a lot of stress on your heart
over the years
long term but when you pass 50 there is
no long term everything's short term
you got to be realistic after 50 there
is no longer any long term everything's
temporary everything is short term
so you just want to stay on top
of a
castle built on a sand foundation you're
just trying to stay
that's what's happening
yeah oracle says the rock always looks
like he's enjoying what he's doing he is
and that's sexy yeah that's what i mean
he just seems like a fun dude yeah and
then oracle said plus my ovaries
exploded at the photo of the rock
cuddling his newborn baby daughters yeah
yeah everybody's gonna love that
difference between okay
or if you see like kind of like hot guys
with like snuggling a kitty yeah
there was a big difference between the
rock
and his generation of guys
and the golden era body builders of the
70s the big difference and the
difference was is that the rock was not
a bodybuilder
the rock was a wrestler yeah okay
so
you're not dealing with these hyper
nitpicky [ __ ]
possessed little [ __ ] about
your muscle insertions and what
striations look like and god damn it you
do not look like an anatomy poster you
know i mean that
the bodybuilders of the
are are perfectionists and there is a
little bit of the pros i think
there's a little bit of a screw loose in
there there there it's lighting out
screw this it's like body dysmorphia
okay but not wrestlers wrestlers were
actors and performers and putting on
shows like something out of the carnival
yeah circus so they try to entertain
they had a lot better and they weren't
looking for perfection they were like
generalists
i just want to be big and strong look
good get up in the ring yeah and look
good in the costume yeah in a costume
yeah be healthy yeah strong i'll throw
your ass yeah you know so they're a lot
more fun yeah they're already dealing
with a more fun personality
so the wrestlers are going to be
selected towards personability
you know what i mean yeah but not not
bodybuilders
yeah because they don't have to be
charming they just have to stand there
and have all of their
body muscles the way they're supposed to
be pro bodybuilders going to tend
towards neurosis
being neurotic
well like i said it's just like any you
know for example like you know women
that compete in you know beauty pageants
or
you know something like that
um where everything exactly what's gonna
be more fun
miss america or a [ __ ] porn star the
porn star is gonna be so more fun
yeah not not miss america because and
like i said because porn is a lot larger
pool it's like everybody relax
everybody's not worried about oh my god
she has like yeah three ounces of fat
like
right yeah they're just kind of like
whatever they're like yeah you got some
nice teddies that hit it
get up on that bus
[Laughter]
jump on all them dudes
you know that's what it's gonna be like
so you're gonna you're dealing with a
more relaxed situation and more friendly
people who
are a little bit more jack of all trades
who can do a little bit of everything
bodybuilders were not from that era just
were not like that they're obsessed
i mean and really anybody that's
obsessed with one thing yeah is not
really that fun to hang around i mean
just in general no matter what that one
thing is i have to back off what i'm
saying i said bodybuilders i meant pro
bodybuilders i'm not talking about just
gym rats that's a big difference
because a lot of those porn stars are
also gym rats they'll go to gym they
work out they take all these same drugs
or hormones
um they get the same surgeries and stuff
it's just a lot of times it's just that
the level of [ __ ] neuroses is nowhere
near
you know yeah they're not just obsessed
with [ __ ] perfection i mean too i
mean to a degree i think it's i mean
it's good to like be interested in stuff
and to like have you know ambition and
whatnot but
to get so so involved in this one thing
it'd be just like this tiny little like
oh my god i have to this little muscle
has to be like this and this but that's
just really not mentally healthy i can
see how you would just go off the deep
end and like i said no but no one's
going to want to hang out with you
yeah now um
i can't read that nom fornic i said hulk
hogan was a bodybuilder before wrestling
yeah yeah that's true yeah i guess so
yeah but he wasn't uh he wasn't a
successful
you know i mean [ __ ] world
[ __ ] renowned bodybuilder
what i gotta do is just look at hulk
hogan hulk hogan didn't hulk hogan
looked good in the [ __ ] wrestling in
a wrestling ring but tearing the shirt
over yeah but that's not
that's not what a real pro bodybuilder
of the you see the 70s in the 80s was
very much about aesthetics
there's a you're not dealing with a
sport there's no score it's just what
the judge is like
what you're talking about is a beauty
contest yeah okay
and when they say aesthetics it doesn't
it's not just the muscles it's also what
they think of that dude's face too and
what they think of his personality
and how he's posing in his routine and
his little top buttons yeah just
well i think there's also and noah
definitely later on
in olympia
it had a lot to do with the man's
[ __ ] status too and his clown because
arnold was winning it when he shouldn't
have won it
at times arnold comes back to compete
he's been gone for a couple years you
know i mean he gets up there on stage he
looks all right but the other guys
looked better but we're gonna give it to
arnold and there's because you're arnold
[ __ ] you know you're the [ __ ] you put
it on the map thank you thank you thank
you nah he shouldn't have won that yeah
and everybody else is like looking
daggers back i remember do we watch that
documentary about that
yeah
well yeah anything that's kind of just
based on uh subjective
aesthetic point of view like i said ice
when i was a little kid
um you know and like miss america and
all that kind of stuff with the scent
was a thing it's like sometimes it'd be
on like because my grandma would watch
it and so sometimes i would watch it and
it's like the girl that i thought was
the prettiest never won
so for a long time i was like is there
something that matter with me it's like
i never i'm not saying the ones that one
like weren't pretty because a lot of
them kind of look the same i know it's
like you know i guess they get the same
plastic surgeon and the same hairdresser
and stuff but i don't know it's like
always the one that i thought was the
prettiest or the most interesting
looking was never though on that one i
don't think i ever
predicted like which one was gonna win
like in all the ones that i watched when
i was growing up so
but you know i you know when i was a kid
i had a [ __ ] i had a crush on [ __ ]
uh lurch from the adams family so what
the [ __ ] do i know
i don't know i don't know what's
attractive and not
you know
i've come i've made my peace with that
situation
yeah and oracle's saying too especially
because aesthetics change from
generation to generation exactly i kind
of feel like
yeah that's the thing like people that
were sex symbols i don't know i kind of
feel like to some degree people that
were sex symbols in different eras are
still like if you showed them to
somebody nowadays and said hey this is
somebody from nowadays people be like
yeah they're pretty sexy or whatever but
dude there are kind of like different i
think particularly with women like
particularly body styles
seem to have been
more popular during various times
because i do kind of feel like
particularly in the 90s
was it the 90s that had that kind of
heroin chic kind of thing like
especially like in modeling and all that
kind of stuff everybody had to look like
and i guess the 70s to some extent too
where but it looked like a scrawny coke
[ __ ] but um it feels like with no tits
and no hips and [ __ ] like that
yeah yeah that wasn't a good time do you
remember so wasn't that
wasn't that like mtv didn't cindy
crawford have some [ __ ] show on mtv
house of style was that what it was
called
i don't even remember i don't really
remember if i saw it but i just remember
kind of it being in the
in the culture at the time because i was
kind of only in my 20s then i think
but i kind of feel like for a long time
like a lot of the models were like super
super scrawny and like super super pale
like they all looked like drug addicts
for a while do you remember that tom
in the 90s when all the models and stuff
looked like they were on heroin yeah a
lot of them were
well yeah well because that was kind of
like the look that everybody's going for
then they look like [ __ ] if you ask me
i never liked those model girls
and then i kind of feel like the 70s was
like that too everybody had to look like
these scrawny cokers like i said i've
seen some movies from the 70s and some
of the actresses that are in those
movies i'm just like do those women eat
what the [ __ ]
they put
how do they get into those [ __ ] pants
how'd they get his pants and it's like
you could see their [ __ ] pelvic bones
like sticking out of the pants i'm like
do they have to like use a shoe horn to
get your ass into those pants holy [ __ ]
they were like the plainest things ever
they were like these i don't know
pie ball gingers with no real facial
features and no eyelashes
uh you know what i mean like they might
have eyebrows but no eyelashes
just weird weird weird-looking santa
said i like skinny girls well some
people do
you know what i mean so like i said
people like shapely people like all
different things yeah uh dermot says
marilyn monroe wouldn't make it today
which is sad if she looked great i don't
know she might but
she would be not she'd be unnoticed
prob well yeah she might be because she
was
i mean she's a beautiful girl but
there's a lot of because of the advent
of
instagram instagram surgeries yeah yeah
you can just [ __ ] man you can just go on
instagram
and
see like regular ass people just in
their house
there's beautiful people everywhere
yeah
you know i don't i don't know how many
youngsters we have in the chat
but uh you youngsters yeah back in the
day before the internet and things like
in instagram
you only
saw real good looking people on
television
and movies
and you'd kind of ogle them they were
like the social media of the day
and then you were like lucky to see you
saw a real good-looking person you
thought it was unusual wow yeah they're
like wow
yeah wow you know it was like a big deal
but now that you have social media you
realize how many people like look like
that
yeah i mean [ __ ] there's like a lot of
people are like super good looking yeah
and you got girls in porn now that are
better looking than stars
than hollywood stars
you got
you can go on on instagram
and some of those instagram models that
keep saying they're in dubai dubai dubai
and qatar and weird [ __ ] like that
they're all hookers all right they look
better than any [ __ ] hollywood
hollywood [ __ ] superstar
you know oh and it's a hooker and secret
being a lot of them aren't actually in
dubai but you can actually rent for not
very expensive yeah uh backdrops
various places to make it look like
you're in different places like a lot of
instagram influencers do that i think
it's like three hundred dollars for a
couple of hours or six hundred dollars
for a couple hours something like that
um they have all these different
backgrounds that look like
um you know cruise ships or it's like
look like these really super high-end
apartments oh this is my apartment
that's my little place
so a lot of the like real like high-end
like instagram influencers some of that
not all of them i'm sure
but uh some of them actually just do
rent yeah uh these kind of like studios
that are meant to look like they're
specifically for that which i thought
was very very funny like i read a whole
like
i read like a whole like [ __ ] piece
about that it was like really
interesting yeah but there are um
dubai is filled with high-end hookers
from all over europe in the united
states yeah and russia in there
and you know we're talking you know
a thousand at least to play
you know they're not cheap
but that's no that's not a big deal in
dubai they got a lot of money over there
well yeah a thousand dollars like a
[ __ ] buck yeah you know they don't
care but like i said well in a way once
a year i kind of like like i said i like
the way it is nowadays because you know
there's a lot of competition obviously
especially if you're a creator it's like
really hard to get noticed because
there's so many people doing it but in a
way i think that's really cool because
it's like everybody
not everybody but you know most people
have the means to make something if they
want to make it and you can kind of
build up your own thing no i was
laughing about like when we were talking
about like instagram influencers and
stuff like that and i think i've
mentioned her before but i really like
this uh this girl named jade the libra
who does she does mostly halloween stuff
and
you know cleaning and decorating her
house for halloween and stuff like that
she's really into halloween and spooky
[ __ ]
um and she is a gorgeous gorgeous girl
and i guess she does like a lot of
instagram influencer stuff too because
she's always getting like free [ __ ] like
free makeup and clothes and what not
like goth clothes and stuff and she's
like super cute but i was watching this
one video that she did a couple years
ago she does like a vlog around
christmas time where she just vlogs
every day just whatever the [ __ ] she's
doing just like bacon muffins or going
to the grocery store or whatever and
it's like she's in the car she has like
these little uh chihuahuas she has two
chihuahuas and um she had the chihuahua
in the car she's taking him to the vet
and she's like every time i put him in
the car he just like poops in the car
and then she's like cleaning up dog poop
like on the thing and it's like she
drops the camera and she's just like you
guys you just fell into the poop and
it's just like it's so [ __ ] funny
because she's just like this gorgeous
girl like this gorgeous makeup and
perfect nails and everything like that
and she's just like the [ __ ] dog is
pooping in her car and it's just that
makes me laugh and i'm just like only on
youtube would you see something like
that
where it's like because she seems like
she's beautiful but she seems like a
real person you know what i mean she's
like hey she has pat's pets poop in her
car just like the rest of us plebes
well what's happened is is that um
i mean i go and look at
[ __ ]
like old television programs we do stop
it poke it
and stuff that's just highly engineered
and edited [ __ ] that we used to watch in
the 90s and it's unwatchable now
just unwatchable
and that's that comes from watching
youtube i watch youtube a lot
you know
and for some reason it just changed
people's tastes social media has
replaced television like i said i think
people like to connect with other people
that are real people yes um because i
think for a long time and this kind of
goes back to like the old days like the
golden era of hollywood where everything
was like everyone's image was very
manufactured and it's like you know you
can't you know it's particularly back
then in the old studio system when you
were like under contract to one studio
and they would like keep [ __ ] man some
of the students will like cover up
murders and [ __ ] like that yeah um you
know what i mean because they wanted
that image of their star to be like
untainted yeah and it was only later
that some of that [ __ ] came out so it's
just i think people kind of got
sick of
seeing these people that are kind of
like these beautiful people that are
like up on pedestals and they seemed
like they weren't real yeah it seemed
like it wasn't a real person so i kind
of feel like nowadays it's much it's
much cooler to have somebody who even
though they might be beautiful and look
perfect and everything like that but
they just have like a regular ass life
like you have with dogs pooping in their
car a lot of that had to do with
keeping everything up on high like it
was authorities figures
and they used it as a means of control
and propaganda you know this is it's
well known um
and it was uh
always a way of the ruling class to keep
control of the minds of of the workers
um
it's now failing and looking
now we know what the ruling class is
really like
but we know [ __ ] that we never would
have known in the 20s
the thing though i mean hugo was talking
about like real reality shows killed the
tv um i think they did but the thing
about reality shows
beginning of social media yeah and well
the thing about it too is that other
than maybe the first season of mtv's the
real world which was kind of one of the
first reality shows everybody knew it
wasn't real um yeah well that one was
pretty good but even after like as time
went on uh reality shows got less and
less real because all you're seeing even
though they say they film everything but
they still edit things to
put across a certain you know we have to
have like this character in this case so
they kind of edit things in a way that
it's like they make more conflict and
[ __ ] like that which or make things seem
like not really so that's why i think
people like
youtube because even though
you know that [ __ ] can be edited too
obviously but a lot of people are just
making their own [ __ ] yeah and just kind
of like putting themselves out there i
remember rewards and all which i think
people appreciate i remember the
beginning of reality tv
the beginning of reality tv as far as i
know based on my personal experience of
being there at the time
was the morton downey jr show
that was the beginning of it
and that was kind of like reality tv
for the time well all of those kind of
talk shows were sort of like that and
they were none of those were really they
weren't real but they seemed to be real
back because he was sitting there being
rude to the guest and [ __ ]
you know talking [ __ ] and it was a
sensation
and then right after that or maybe
around that same time you started to see
things you know well actually i guess
no before that time you already had [ __ ]
like ricky lake and all that
didn't you well you had like i mean in
the 80s you had like
in the 80s you had geraldo you had sally
jesse raphael
um you had donahue although that was
pretty restrained uh that was usually
just him kind of like interviewing
people i don't remember that being like
super
egregious
um but as time went on the reality shows
got more and more crazy yeah and like
and yeah to the point where it's funny
because like um
you know dan bell he does he takes like
some old clips of like some of those old
reality shows like jenny jones and stuff
and like puts them on uh on some of his
videos and it's like it's just funny to
watch him now because it's obviously
fake
but in the time you didn't see it that
way because remember how fake the
sitcoms were yeah the sitcoms were
becoming
absolutely unwatchable just the fake
laugh tracks jokes that weren't funny
the [ __ ] was just it was just coming off
of a [ __ ] production mill
yeah you know what i mean [ __ ]
all those stupid sitcoms that they had
i kind of feel like the worst and i do
want and i you know i i do like some of
the ones from back then still
but yeah ones like three's company stuff
like that that i grew up watching
they just seem very
contrived nowadays yeah
different strokes because like you said
they just had these really like
contrived situations yeah yeah and uh
you know webster
yeah i remember that one
you know and like you know it's like
somebody would like say a funny line
then they'd make like a little face like
oh yeah i'm like everybody like
laugh track you know what i mean
like vaultville yeah you can i don't
yeah you can really
i'm kind of i remembered as a kid that
was kind of like reality tv the one that
blew me away were the the california uh
game shows
like
hollywood squares
that was [ __ ] hilarious because that
was kind of like reality tv i used to i
used to still really like it
yeah because yeah
you had [ __ ] people on there just
drunk drunk as [ __ ] especially what's
his name in there [ __ ] what was the
gay dude's name again [ __ ] poland
paul lid yeah paul lynn would be in
there he'd be tearing that [ __ ] show
up
they had to keep his ass under control
and then they'd have [ __ ] just
oh man
[ __ ] what was that [ __ ] chick's
name
oh man
i remember was phyllis diller on there i
was thinking of phyllis diller see i can
read you phyllis diller would [ __ ]
say [ __ ] would go right over my head
because i was a little kid i couldn't
understand everything that they were
talking about everything was a sexual
injury everything was sex everything was
about sex and it was all these sexual
innuendos and you had to be a [ __ ]
adult to understand everything but i
could kind of sometimes catch about half
of it and i was [ __ ] just laughing
man
paul in that [ __ ] was a damn
genius
comedian
and he'd be you could see him sitting
there and in between takes him pouring
[ __ ] booze in his [ __ ] glass and
he put the glass out because they'd be
filming them they'd fill up six seven of
them things a day yeah they'd be there
all day they're like all day [ __ ]
sitting here all day without booze [ __ ]
yeah
and i kind of watched that i always
wanted this show to be kind of like
hollywood squares man just or we just
get like super drunk
[ __ ] say some [ __ ] yeah it's really
getting like all sexual in your way well
not even inuit
those are all still up on youtube you
can find
the old one what was the one what was
the one
club was another that's a good one yeah
and so was joker's wild shoulder sword
was a little oh man i used to love the
joker's joker's wild was a little faster
but the liars club was more [ __ ]
buddy hackett and [ __ ] people just
drunk
lying
over objects
yes this is a uh and you had in the
contestants had to figure out who was
telling the truth everybody else is
lying they're all pretending like
they're lying only one of them was
telling the truth
and they would give they would pass
around an unidentifiable object and each
one would lie would make up a make up a
story about what it was only one of them
was telling the truth
but you couldn't tell because they were
all [ __ ] fantastic liars every one of
them was a good liar
yeah
just like i said that's a great [ __ ]
idea
i also used to be kind of amused by the
newlywed game
um even though that was like super
cheesy but there's something about that
70s because i because remember in the
70s when there was kind of i don't know
how many people were actually doing this
but there was this whole like
uh cultural thing for like you know
swinging and like hey we're married but
we're going to porn together
and they had all these like dirty board
games
which they still have but i kind of feel
like it was kind of trendy in the 70s
and i feel like a newlywed game kind of
came out of that so it was i think the
rule was did chuck willary host that or
am i completely crazy but um i can't
remember who hosted it now i thought it
was chuck woolery but maybe i'm totally
wrong um
but the rule was you had to have been
married less than two years
and then they would ask you well they
would ask you a question
the newlywed game okay yeah yeah and
then they would ask you a question and
it was always dirty it was always like
some kind of sexual innuendo thing
um and each one of the couple would have
to like come up with the answer and then
they'd see like how good they were like
how well they knew each other i guess
kind of thing yeah and i don't know
something about that show was always
like funny to me they were talking about
the match game
in the comments section yeah remember
that one i remember a vaguely another
one that i used to like
that involved a [ __ ] slime ball
and he was drunk half the time when he
doing this [ __ ] was called the original
family feud with [ __ ] richard dawson
yeah that dude oh and that dude was a
groper he would grope the [ __ ] out of
the women and start [ __ ] flirting
he's just drunk off his [ __ ] ass he
was [ __ ] funny though yeah
and let me say something
bob eubanks thank you i knew why am i
thinking chuck woolery what the [ __ ] did
he host
but yeah richard dawson richard dawson
he was in the running man yeah he is
great in the running man yeah great
because he's such a sleaze yeah
but no he did a great job he was very
believable well that's why it was funny
because yeah
they knew exactly what they were doing
when they cast that dude
they said family feud's still on you
know that right
i'm pretty sure it's still yeah it's not
the it's it's not the same it's not the
same well like i said the the show the
game shows from the 70s like you said a
lot were a lot more fun because they
they were live well the thing about it
is that it even if the ones nowadays
were dirty it wouldn't be fun anymore
because it's like every everything is
out there everything's dirty back in the
70s you had to hide them you couldn't
really get away with saying sexual [ __ ]
on tv like especially at 7 00 p.m like
after dinner because you know kids were
still awake and stuff so you had to be
like real creative
about the [ __ ] that you said like the
innuendo that you came up with
so you see i was living in california at
that time and in california they were
alive
yeah you know i think the rest of the
nation got them recorded
you know what i mean because for
different time zones yeah but they were
shooting them live and that was just
normal for for hollywood you know
california at the time they were live tv
had been going on since the 50s
but the rest of the nation got it on
delay yeah but uh
so there was kind of like an element of
[ __ ] circus to it you never know what
was gonna happen
some [ __ ] would get bleeped
yeah i remember that [ __ ] but you gotta
be pretty quick on the bleep button some
of it was live but i don't think it was
all alive because some of the [ __ ] like
you said was recorded many of them in a
single day but some of this [ __ ] i
remember being alive i think
i think i think jeopardy might have been
live huh
oh i'm not sure or not but the thing
about it is right even when [ __ ] is live
yeah um it's usually on like a five or
ten second delay yeah um
so for that reason like if somebody says
something [ __ ] up or somebody yeah
from what i remember the big shows like
price is right i think we're live in
california oh my god my grandma loved
friends
yeah and then when i was growing up we
would always watch that in the mornings
i remember that one being the biggest
one all the old ladies love the [ __ ]
prices right yeah like i said
to [ __ ] had to know what the price of
something was i was i was so bad at that
show yeah well just i kind of feel like
i don't know man it's like i went to the
grocery store and [ __ ] like that but
it's like i don't know how much anything
costs old ladies no they did yeah they
wanted to know oh here that would be you
know this and that you know my
grandmother would be watching because
that's the california price that's not
work they get mad yeah it's not worth
that here in mississippi well yeah
because [ __ ] was cheaper it was cheaper
maybe that's why maybe everything seemed
like although some things seemed like
cheaper than i was expecting too well
because it wasn't always you didn't
always have to like identify like
expensive [ __ ] because sometimes some of
the games were like hey here's a candle
like [ __ ] baked beans or something
like that right you had to put the
prices on things and [ __ ] you had to
guess what the price had price had to be
within certain things they had a lot of
different games
it was pretty good but i remember liking
it as a kid trying to follow it yeah it
was fun yeah
although remember how excited everybody
got when they rolled out plinko because
they only did that like a couple of
times
every it was the one with that big board
and it's like you had to go up to the
top and they give you a big drop it's a
metal disc
it's like pachinko yeah i don't know why
everybody got so excited about it
because they didn't do it that often so
it's like it's like oh my god they're
doing play games
it's [ __ ] funny that we came from
this culture that's long gone this is
this is the forgotten culture people
sergeant rocco says what was the one
with monty hall that was let's make a
deal yeah let's make a deal that was a
good one too i remember that one you
guys are you guys are bringing it back
that's what everybody for whatever
reason you came in uh in costume yeah
for some reason yeah uh and you sat in
the audience and you had to make a deal
over what's behind this [ __ ] curtain
and then at the end monty hall would go
to various people in the audience and
you would ask them if they had something
in their person like something weird
yeah if they had it then you got money
and then you got money so it's just kind
of like do you have a hard-boiled egg in
there and like some people did because
like some people would think ahead and
they'd be like i have to bring like
every crazy [ __ ] thing i can think of
in my [ __ ] handbag
[Laughter]
yeah and that was the audience
participation there it was they dress up
in costumes and wait outside until the
show started and they all come in
[ __ ] trying to play so the people in
the audience that was a wild ass game
the people in the audience were eligible
to be up on stage yeah so they were
jacked trying to get to miss like what
price is right was like that too wasn't
it weren't they pulling them out of the
audience
yes and playing with them yeah well they
what they would do is they would call
people's names from the audience no one
was dressed up but they would call um
and i think there was
how many people was it five people and i
think there was like five people in the
front
and then
uh so there'd be five people in the
front and then they would give you one
thing to bid on it was usually like a
washer dryer or some [ __ ] like that and
everybody would bid on it and the one
that got the closest got to come up on
the stage and play the game yeah so some
of the people like they would get
consolation prizes and [ __ ] but it's
like some of the people didn't uh just
stayed down there and didn't get
anything they didn't get to come up it's
funny how you guys are bringing this up
mandy nicole says mountain climber oh i
remember that one too like it had the
little guy at the bottom and if you
every time you got something right like
he would go
dude
the little [ __ ] uh yodeling kind of
song that he did for you youngsters
that [ __ ] there
those those games shows they probably
they're probably still around
well pluto tv sergeant rocket just
pointed out pluto tv has a couple of uh
old game show channels okay so they just
play the old game shows yeah yeah that's
a good idea well like i said playing
streaming i i watched them there's an
mst3k channel and a rifftrax channel and
yeah those game shows were like national
events
back in the 70s and the 80s the early
early 80s they were that was like
that was like our version of social
media or [ __ ] reality tv those damn
game shows now old ladies watched them
even back then but you but as a kid
you'd get caught up in them too they
were fun games and they were very
exciting like the whole crowd was
excited and you're kind of rooting to
see if they're going to win
win this prize and you didn't have
anything to gain out of it or lose
there's just something about it you'd
try to start rooting for it i used to
[ __ ] love jeopardy man yeah jeopardy
was the one you had to guess
well that was trivia questions trivia
okay the truth what was the one where
you had the wheel of fortune wheel of
fortune well the fortune was fun too
you're trying to sit spell out what it
is and they gotta [ __ ] hit them it's
like hangman but yeah sorta
but actually uh let's make a deal and
price is right we're more complicated
and more entertaining they weren't as
focused we never knew what was going to
happen it was crazy what was the one
what the [ __ ] was that one where no
whammies no whammies no whammies what
was that called press your luck was it
called that sounds familiar
yeah where it's like a thing would go
around and then there'd be like a little
monster like you had to push the the
plunger thing down yeah and then if you
got the little and if you got the little
monster guy like all your points got
taken away
am i am i yeah am i high yeah no it
sounds familiar but i don't remember
that that was a real thing right i
remember
i remember really liking joker's wild
i like yeah i liked that one too yeah i
think it was you know why i liked
joker's wild when i was a little kid is
because it's kind of like a card game
right but it was like a it was like a
card game but also like a um
like a slot machine yeah sort of like a
slot machine because you'd pull this big
like lever and i remember you had to bat
things and ask questions yeah something
like that but i think i liked it
i liked it because when you got the
joker it kind of looked like the devil
yeah and uh and i was super into the
devil when i was a little kid this is
because because i was evil even when i
was a child um i was super obsessed with
whatever that um what's that brandon
like deviled ham yeah underwood
underwood devil hand yeah and it was
just like this little can and my
grandmother always had some
and it had like a little devil on it
that was like their logo and i used to
think that was so [ __ ] cool don't
tell sandra about that she ain't buying
that
i got it i didn't like it i didn't eat
it i just thought the package was cool
because it had a devil on it i was like
oh that's badass i already got her on
peanut butter next thing you know she's
gonna be looking for underwood deviled
ham all right sandra we had this [ __ ]
called deviled ham
it came in a little can that big around
about an inch tall
and the can was wrapped in paper yeah
white paper was classy yeah they [ __ ]
said underwood deviled ham and then it
had a little red devil with a pitchfork
yeah he was like yeah and you had to
pull it out of there and man i thought
that was so cool open it up and open it
up like cat food and it was a pate yeah
oh i never ate it i thought it was gross
but i thought i thought the package was
cool though it was a pate it was like a
ham pate
it was
what what
what
she said
it kind of had a vinegary taste like it
had been um pickled slightly pickled
yeah
and you spread it on crackers
crackers or uh bread i might eat it now
but on crackers i don't think i would
make a sandwich out of it because that'd
be kind of nasty yeah crackers um but we
used to make sandwiches out of it too
you just uh toast some white bread and
you put mayonnaise on one piece and
deviled ham on the other put it together
and eat it like that yeah just like that
that was some ghetto [ __ ] man
that's some ghetto [ __ ] not as ghetto is
putting just like one [ __ ]
round thing of oscar mayer baloney on
there not as ghetto as potted meat
that's true not as ghetto as vietnam
sausage oh my god my dad loved those
yeah
we always love being a sausage i know
that's such a dad thing they still sell
them too it's in the grocery store i
think pookie wants the blessing come on
poop outside does she have her clothes
on let's see
she better have her clothes on
she just she
her thing now is she likes to go out on
the front porch and she just like sits
in the planter
and she's like hey i'm getting my bottle
dirty
then you open the door you like want to
come in she's like no
i'm just sitting out here sitting in the
[ __ ] planner watching the [ __ ]
world go by
uh yeah like spam yeah it's [ __ ]
gross yeah they're still devil damn and
just you know they still sell vienna
sausages too it's just that
my dad uh was super into vienna sausages
so we always had cans of them in the
cupboard
and he would just like take them out i'd
like i ate him when i was really little
but because when i didn't know any
better
and um you know but just like he would
take him out like dipping my mustard and
stuff it's like even the smell of them
like brings back
weird childhood memories
i'm like
yeah you know what i mean like living in
the [ __ ]
trailer park or whatever like with the
[ __ ]
i said the the smell of uh those vienna
sausages i can't even remember what
brand it is but it reminds me of being
is are they hormel yeah hormel made them
i think well there are several companies
but i know but i'm trying to think of
like the one that my dad always had
devil ham
i mean
i don't know i'm always kind of
i've always been kind of like weirded
out by canned meat
you know what i mean i don't for
whatever reason like i don't mind canned
tuna that's fine they say you can still
find deviled ham yeah yeah deviled ham
sandwich they know about them yeah
um and we've we've had canned chicken
like we've made things with canned
chicken before like we made chicken
salad or like chicken salad pot pie and
stuff and that's fine
but i don't know there's something like
i don't
there's something
i don't really like about canned meat
i know i'm not really super into like
canned veggies either depending on what
the veggie is some of them don't some of
them gross me out more than others like
when i was a kid
we always had canned
uh like green beans and stuff like that
and i just always thought they were kind
of gross
um
so [ __ ] like green beans and stuff like
that those are always like way better
if they're fresh you're talking about
spam i'm a fan of spam i got a lot of
spam he's a spam fan yeah they got they
got flavor i should take you to the spam
museum one of these days you want to get
the low sodium spam i think it's in
akron ohio you want to get the low
sodium spam because the problem with
spam is it's too [ __ ] salty all right
but the low sodium is a lot better and
they got flavored stuff now like bacon
flavor
jalapeno flavor chorizo flavor
they got good flavors slice it thin
and fry it first and then put it on
sandwich
or put it in a ramen
dice it fry it put it in ramen
do whatever you want with it it's good
even the low sodium one is a little too
salty for me i feel some people were
thinking well that's mystery meat but no
it is not it's just pork shoulder it's
poor shoulder
i think the thing that's upsetting about
it to me yeah um is that one it's too
salty it's too salty and two
i don't like i just have this vision
when i was a kid of just turning the can
upside down and then it just coming out
and just like glistening
with that kind of yeah the glitter slime
on the outside and it going like pop
it's cooked in the can nuts
but you know that plopping noise as it
hits the plate not super appealing gotta
say
you just gotta know what to do with it i
know well like i said i'll eat it like
cause you've made it like you fried it
and like and cut it in pieces and like
put it in scrambled eggs or an omelette
or something good for breakfast it's
okay like that although i would rather
have deli ham if we're gonna do ham and
an omelette i would rather have deli ham
spam is the original
mre
the us army [ __ ]
basically mandated spam
spam was in a ration world war ii the
world war ii
american armed forces was spam powered
spam and crackers and [ __ ] cheese
cheese whiz
that's what they lived on not foreign
spam is actually really popular in
hawaii yes it is yeah they have whole
[ __ ] cuisine based around spam yeah
spam sandwiches barbecue spam sandwich
and [ __ ] and and pineapple
there's a bunch of good
hawaiian recipes for spam
it's because spam hawaii just has fish
and lobster
there's no room for cows there and beef
is super expensive so they just buy spam
honestly i'd rather eat fish and lobster
if that was they get sick of that i
wouldn't get sick of it i love seafood
man when i was in the army there were
guys from micronesia wouldn't touch
lobster they're like
like you don't eat lobsters we got so
much of that micronesia did they give
that away for free at the at the bar
just take it yeah
they get away for free at the bar i love
seafood i can eat seafood every day i
would
get sick of it they're just sick of it
sergeant rocco says there's a restaurant
here that serves old 70s fads grilled
spam with catalina dressing also the
diet plate a hamburger patty with
cottage cheese
i was like i love it [ __ ] there do they
have something where they serve and i'm
trying to remember what all right
what all the components of this were
although that's a little that's a little
older than seven yes i feel
like i kind of feel like 70s was more
like let's put a big lettuce like
iceberg lettuce leaf some cottage cheese
yeah a pear or a pineapple ring yeah
with cottage cheese in the middle or and
or sometimes they had like american
cheese in here somewhere too because i
kind of feel like my grandmother made
that a lot yeah just because that's what
they had where's like canned pears with
like
american cheese no no no on it no no
you're wrong
no i'm not yes you are it is you weren't
there with my i know you weren't there
with my w what my grandma made i know
what she made they don't okay
the most common one was a half a pair
with a big dollop of [ __ ] mayonnaise
in the middle of it yeah she made that
braided [ __ ] cheddar cheese yeah she
made that too they called that pear
salad although normally we didn't have
cheddar so i think she put american
cheese on yeah not good
well no it's actually not bad
it's just like why would you eat it
i mean it's not bad it's just i've
gotten to a point now where it's kind of
like look if you're gonna eat x amount
of calories yeah don't eat that you
might as well enjoy them yeah
um i don't know how many calories that
is like half a canned pear with cottage
cheese or whatever no it's like not sour
cream it was mayonnaise
yeah so whatever it was but um
you know how many calories is that i'm
sure you could find something much
better
to eat with the same amount of calories
than that the variety wasn't there in
the 60s that's all i'm saying they just
had a bunch of canned stuff it was cheap
it wasn't much variety but i remember
when you're talking about
you take a ring you took a ring of
pineapple and then dropped a bunch of
[ __ ] cottage cheese in the middle of
it it was personal as a piece of lettuce
yeah yeah like a big iceberg lettuce
yeah on a plate and on a little plate
about that big she had to have a piece
of lettuce and then you put a ring of
pineapple and then an ice cream scoop of
[ __ ] cottage cheese boom
it might have had a it might have had a
a cherry on the top of it didn't it
yeah you could do that because that's
fancy that's [ __ ] crazy
i mean
yeah
yeah he said they do serve that at the
restaurant yeah you know what i mean so
yeah they know what we're talking about
yeah he says uh yes the restaurant
serves half a
cling peach like yeah
on top of the cottage cheese yeah peach
and cottage cheese peach or a pear i've
seen pear done as well uh but it's
always out of a cake an apple always out
of candy because they ate out of the
cans back then
because that was some fancy [ __ ] yeah
i mean that's an mre [ __ ] that's that's
the [ __ ] that astronauts had
well there was a time like i said i've
seen a lot of kind of like um
shorts that they showed in like schools
and stuff back then because they've done
them like on mst and canned food the
weight yeah it was like a big deal well
it's like you can have
well back in before they had canning
before they had like preservation
you could only have certain foods at
certain times a year right and like if
you lived in certain parts of the
country you couldn't have
particular foods so canning and stuff
that's a big deal we can have oranges
all year round even though we don't live
in an area where they grow oranges and
it's like a big deal i get it
but when they can stuff it's like a lot
i don't know it's just it just takes a
lot of the [ __ ] flavor away and then
like i said yeah they used to boil the
[ __ ] out of everything too yeah they
boil all the [ __ ] flavor and
nutrients out of anything throw the
water yeah so it's like give you a
[ __ ] piece why bother eating it at
that point it's just like it's just this
nasty sad it's not even giving you any
like nutrients they didn't know what
they were doing no clearly
yes canned pudding is not good
they used to give it to us in our
lunches we were little kids you pull the
top off of it and get a little chocolate
buddies yeah remember this i still like
those and i was super they tasted good
but
only the chocolate though the other
flavors could [ __ ] off i didn't like
vanilla or butterscotch or anything i
thought they tasted weird i liked them
all i liked them but the chocolate was
okay i liked them all equally
i would eat anything as a kid
i think well most little kids would
i don't know i kind of feel like kids
were really picky i wouldn't
i didn't know the difference
i would eat bologna and just love it
wasn't it yeah i did too i was like a
little bit older and i realized no
baloney sucks i would eat a raw hot dog
thinking that it was great yeah i used
to eat those all the time you could just
open the fridge and like
the [ __ ] was i thinking yeah well it's
really weird because i don't know about
kids nowadays but
when we were growing up
kids were really
it's weird because in a way they were
picky because they wouldn't eat normal
human food like that people would eat
nowadays yeah but they would eat like
the grossest [ __ ] imaginable yeah
and like some like raw hot dogs or
something and it would be fine i'd say i
mean i did
did all kinds of crazy [ __ ] when i was a
kid i crawled up on top of the damn
counter [ __ ] stood up i had to make a
[ __ ] ladder to get up to the top of
the [ __ ] cupboard and i got the
[ __ ] sugar [ __ ] bundle down and
sat up there with a spoon just eating
sugar
took the lid off the top he's living the
dream
the dream man
got my little ass up there [ __ ]
underwear on just eating [ __ ]
it's like a monk i can see it yeah
teetering
getting ready to put the sugar back at
any moment in case somebody came home
and put the sugar back
close it up that's pretty funny because
i know like a lot of kids me included uh
you know would sneak up in the cabinet
although my parents weren't one of those
like no cookies before dinner they
weren't that bad
but um i know a lot of kids uh parents
were like that
so it's like they had to like sneak and
they'd sneak into the cookie jar or
whatever and that's kind of like a
cliche
but uh i like that you just went right
to the source you're like oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
them [ __ ] the cookies i'm just gonna eat
it
you weren't supposed to eat my mom my
mom my mom had these diet
suppressants and they looked like a
[ __ ] butt he looked like a [ __ ]
were they those chocolatey ones that
were called aids aids i was just gonna
say
a yds yeah this is a real thing that
diet aid yeah it was before the aids
epidemic hit yeah so they had they
came in a package it looked like seas
candies
they were chocolate chewy they tasted
terrible though like wax
and she had him up on top of the
refrigerator i climbed up on top of the
fridge i had those i was so small back
then i had to get on top of the
refrigerator to get to anything little
tom with his little diaper butt like no
i didn't have diapers on but i [ __ ]
probably had shorts on getting up on top
probably have a shirt on just shorts
when i get up there and i see that and
i'm like oh
chocolate candy
you know so i stand up on top of the
[ __ ] refrigerator and i must have ate
about eight eight or nine of those
things man
and
they were appetite suppressants because
one they were they were thick
and real chewy kind of like wax
they tasted like chocolate but they
didn't have much sugar in them they were
like
they were like chocolate flavored
candles
that would be good
all right but they were chewy like
really bad
fudge
and once they got in your stomach they
started to expand to make you feel more
full well you're only just to eat like
one of them i i eat like seven eight
nine of them
[Laughter]
oh
and uh my mom comes home from work you
know i'm going oh my oh it's just what's
wrong you know i said is eating those
chocolates because what chocolate
chocolate's on top of the refrigerator
she goes there's no chocolate she's like
oh you talk about that talk about these
and i was like you ate my aids
i was gonna say at least you didn't eat
the chocolate ex-lax and then tammy said
my older brother got into my mom's
chocolate chocolate eggs last
well that was like a prank that a lot of
people would play back in the day yeah
where they would slip someone some
chocolate hey have some candy and it was
chocolate flavored
and you would shave your pants sure yeah
but uh
well i think we all kind of had the
thing where when we were really little
and i did this too
and i think a lot of kids did this
where you would go into the cabinet
you'd be like ooh candy bar and you
would eat it except it was the uh baking
chocolate yeah you'd eat that too it
wasn't so uh no it's not good not enjoy
well because you're supposed to use it
to bake with so you're supposed to add
sugar to it later so it doesn't like
taste another one i tried to eat was
cake decorations they were the [ __ ]
little sugar numbers oh yeah you age you
know i mean like seven six eight those
are also not so good no my mom bought a
bunch of those so every time i'd get a
little bit older she'd put a [ __ ] new
one on there right well i didn't know
that's where they were coming from i
just found a bunch of
candy numbers tried to eat those things
they were [ __ ] just rock just solid
sugar
i liked them for a little while you're
like oh yeah these are good
concentrated
did all kinds of [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
sergeant rocket was talking about those
wax soda bottles i remember those
another time i ate almost a whole packet
of those damn [ __ ] silver bee bees
that you put on top of damn cupcakes oh
yeah yeah what do they call those
non-per
p-a-r-e-i-l-s i don't know if they're
like silver bbs yeah we had those yeah i
found them and i was like
they were in there with the food
and i was like these are candy i ate a
bunch of those but they don't have much
flavor just make it real just real sweet
yeah they don't really taste like
anything
putting whole handfuls in my mouth
that sounds like you trying to chew them
they still sell those when you're a
little kid you know what i mean you're
almost you're animalistic
you know you just try to eat everything
it looks like candy yeah you gotta put
it right in my mouth that's all i'm
gonna do remember eating it yeah well
you know it's
like i said i'm pretty sure they still
make they still make like all those
sprinkles and [ __ ] like that nowadays i
don't know if they taste any better
because i haven't eaten them personally
but uh i was just watching
i was watching a video the other day on
uh
larry voltaire and he was making some
halloween cupcakes
and he had bought a whole bunch of like
halloween sprinkles they were like
sprinkles but they were like shaped like
little bats and pumpkins and [ __ ] yeah
but so i guess you i mean you can eat
them but i don't really think they taste
like much of anything they're just kind
of crying somebody's asking if they were
a drink [ __ ] tab
oh my god how bad tab was
honestly i've i drank it but i don't
really remember what it tastes like
there was there was something else i
forgot what it was called maybe some of
you guys might remember it it was before
tab
and it was a coca-cola and i think it
was some kind of a blue came in a blue
can
and it was like it was a diet coca-cola
this is back in the 70s this must have
been 77 76 maybe
i think coca-cola made it
and it was undrinkable unfucking
drinkable i tried to drink it couldn't
drink it adults couldn't drink it
it wasn't tabbed though it was worse it
was in a blue can i think it was i just
remember tab not tasting like much of
anything when tab came out people
thought that it was a lot better than
the other [ __ ] [ __ ] that had just
come out but i don't remember what it
was called yeah well everything sucked
back then so it's like anything else
well and tab was it was it not like
marketed as kind of like a diet it was
drink like they market it to like
dieting women it was one of the first
diet drinks yeah it was supposed to be
coca-cola
but it didn't it had zero sugar in it i
just remember it like not really tasting
like anything bitter
honestly i'm not i'm still not um and
even growing up i was never a big soda
fan
no it's like it wasn't rc cola and it
wasn't mountain thunder it wasn't shasta
i actually quite like i actually quite
liked shasta i don't think it was diet
right
i think it was either in a
in there in a blue can or a pink can
moxie somebody says maybe
it was not for nexus [ __ ] terrible i
mean the [ __ ] was [ __ ] terrible and
they immediately pulled it from the
shelves joe nash says moxie but it was
in an orange can was it an orange can
okay
might have been moxie i'd have to see it
i remember it was the very very first
diet drink
and i remember my mom complaining about
it and all her friends complaining about
it it's like this because they wanted it
it was [ __ ] terrible and i think it
was made by the coca-cola company
and um sergeant rocco said all i
remember is fresca actually i quite
liked fresco yeah fresco was not diet
though uh no but it wasn't a diet fresco
but they did well fresca was kind of
more like what flavor was it supposed to
be fruit fruit yeah it was good real
good i actually quite liked fresco i
used to take it to school with me
sometimes fresca was as good as squirt
it was different than squirt but it was
squirt was that was pre squirt was it
not i i feel like
i feel like squirt i don't i wasn't
aware of s squirt that's a terrible part
was good
i wasn't aware of that until later i
feel like i like fresca
i remember taking
cans of fresca to school with me
sometimes when i was in elementary
school fresh squirt i don't remember
until like maybe the late 80s
in california we had squirted around the
same time we had fresca it was like it
was the answer to fresca
fresca was clear
like yeah um
like sprite or seven sprite or seven up
but it was a real nice
fresh sweet
grapefruit flavor it was kind of
slightly dry at the end but it was good
yeah it wasn't like super it didn't have
a lot of flavor to it but it was just
like refreshing real real refreshing
real good
squirt was extremely citrus it taste it
also tasted
like grapefruit but also like grapefruit
and lemon
almost kind of like a grapefruit
lemonade and it wasn't clear it was
cloudy and yellow
the the original yeah you know what i
mean it was almost looked like juice or
lemon concentrate
it was good
then it started to get a little bit more
corn syrupy i mean it's still okay but i
remember it being really good in the 70s
i mean i'm pretty sure they still sell
fresca nowadays but i'm sure it's a
different recipe just like everything
else
well
there it's all corn syrup now yeah well
that's why everybody started buying like
mexican coke and stuff because it still
has like cane sugar back in the 70s it
was sugar cane and it was and everything
was better the [ __ ] coke was better
the [ __ ] pepsi was better it was just
a better flavor and what's funny and
like
my little old [ __ ] man that i worked
with the [ __ ] electrolux
you ever notice if everybody got fat
everybody's now fat when they got rid of
that sugar cane and put all that corn
syrup of course you all gonna get fat
well yeah corn is what they use to
fatten up cows of chickens because
that's what you give cattle that's what
you said and the thing about corn syrup
is that they put it in
everything
so i i think even [ __ ] that you wouldn't
think would have sugar or sweetener in
it like bread
[ __ ] he said that and he was from he
was an ancient old man back in the 90s
and you know he he came up in the great
depression era
20s and 30s when he was a kid you know
and he said they didn't have fat people
and they would drink
soda and [ __ ] eat things that had
sugar in it all day long and they
wouldn't gain they wouldn't get fat
because and i think he's correct it's
that corn syrup
because that'll make you fat we always
knew that'd make you fat
oh i'm sure that has something to do
with it well yeah because like i said
the obesity did start i don't think
that's the only thing but i think that's
like a big factor a contributing factor
i think it's corn syrup well it's a lot
more concentrated like i said and they
do use corn to fatten up because
honestly like cows and [ __ ] like are not
really supposed to eat corn uh but they
give it to them anyway because it makes
them fatter quicker yeah you know yeah
mellow yellow also came out around the
time of squirt
i remember going to pizza hut when pizza
hut was a sit-down restaurant with a
jukebox
um and we would always get because they
only had pepsi products and i wasn't
super into like pepsi or anything i
wasn't like i said i wasn't super into
soda but everybody else wanted soda so
we always had to get like a pizza and
then we'd get like a big pitcher of
mellow yellow all right they're fighting
over that first
diet soda
yeah look it up because now i'm kind of
curious
moxie sounds right but because i have
heard of that but i don't remember
seeing it so i don't really know i
remember tab
um you know i remember everybody like i
remember that kind of like magenta diet
right yeah it was diet right yeah yeah
it might have been diarrhea okay i
remember that yeah i said it might have
been it was diet diet right let me go
look at it
alex's menorah says pizza hut birthday
parties were legit they were it's like
pizza hut used to be like a pretty good
like when it was a big sit-down
restaurant yeah it's a cola diet right
cola
okay that's not the same 1970s
i like that nowadays most sodas are
giving you a real sugar option yeah
that's it right there it's blue blue and
silver from the 70s yeah i remember that
that's it right there yeah diet right
yeah i don't recall if i ever drank that
or not
i'm pretty sure i drank tab i just don't
really remember what it tasted like i
remember fresca being good
because i remember taking that to school
with me a couple times but i don't
remember i don't remember diet right but
i'm sure my mom had it because my mom
was like on
on weight watchers often
my whole childhood terrible
one calorie
yeah yeah
tab was better than that in comparison
and tab was [ __ ] but still yeah i can't
even remember i don't even think did tab
even taste like anything
tab tasted like cola but bitter
without any sweetener in it originally i
think they changed the way tab tasted
over time like i said i did they still
make it now do they still make top notes
i'm pretty sure they do they might i'm
pretty sure they still make fresco
nowadays too but like i said i don't
think it's the same recipe as it used to
be well even like i said even when i was
a kid i wasn't really into
soda
honestly
i always just drank water out of the tap
or milk or kool-aid
if i had to drink soda i would drink
sprite or seven up
um but i didn't like coke i didn't like
pepsi
i do like like dr pepper i like the
medicine-y tasting ones like dr pepper
and pib i like those
um i like root beer
but
i don't know it just wasn't something i
ever
really wanted
to get what did pip taste like mr pibb
tastes kind of like it kind of tastes
like dr pepper
it kind of tastes like
it's it's kind of a medicine-y kind of
taste i wouldn't call it that sort of
well i'd well i've i say that because
like a lot of people that i know that
have never tasted it before and drank it
said it tastes like medicine
you have a lot of people that say all
kinds of weird [ __ ] they'll say root
beer tastes like medicine depends on
what well because it's sassafras that's
that it's sassafras all right
and there were sassafras tea and
sassafras was used in some ancient
medicines
all right we're talking about the 1800s
all soft drinks were sport drinks they
all had drugs in them back in the days
in the 1800s early 1900s they were in
saloons they were [ __ ] getting loaded
they'd give them those
drinks
a soft drink to pep them up to keep them
drinking alcohol pepsi yeah
okay coca-cola wake up so you can drink
more yeah
the active ingredient was cocaine
later on substituted for the caffeine
dr pepper it would pep you up it was
like a doctor they were sports drinks
all soft drinks started out as medicinal
yeah
you know sort of sort of to a degree
yeah they call it
medicinal but it was they weren't like
tech it was more like quack medicine
yeah but yeah
kind of like a way a sports drink is
that's [ __ ] you know today is sports
drake is it's quackery they taste good i
like them all right like monster and
[ __ ]
but back in those days they just put
cocaine in them they worked that [ __ ]
there worked yeah i mean if and and they
made a lot of sense they were sold out
of saloons
the dude was up at the bar half passed
out give him a soft drink pep his ass up
he went right up have some cocaine yeah
and yeah and order some more whiskey and
he'd order some more [ __ ] whiskey it
worked
okay
pepe right up well
dr pepper
is kind of like cola
with a
a prune flavor i believe it to me i
think it's prunes
okay it may be they won't tell anybody
but you see that's something that they
would have put in medicine back in the
day prunes
prune flavor keep your regular yeah
um mr pibb
tastes like
it might have a little bit of that same
prune style flavor in it
and cream soda
it's kind of like a cream soda if your
head cream soda
it's more like closer to cream soda with
a little bit of duck pepper in it that's
what mr pimp tastes like although it's
weird because i like mr i like root beer
i like mr pibb i like dr pepper i do not
like cream soda i like it it's too sweet
i like cream soda and like red cream
soda
i also like something in michigan they
call red pop red pop is kind of like
cream soda
kind of
with a slight fruit flavor
with a red flavor it just tastes red red
pop red
red
well red is kind of a flavor yeah red is
the flavor
you know
well because sometimes you get like you
know candy that's red or something like
that and they're like oh it's cherry or
strawberry it's not it's not it's just
red it's red flavor
it doesn't taste like actual cherry or
strawberry just kind of tastes red not
that that's bad because i kind of like
red flavor but
but i was gonna say too that
um
when i was a kid i don't know if some of
you guys that are same ages may right
remember but there used to be a cough
syrup
that came in a bottle you could look it
up on there maybe show a picture of it
called cree emulsion
um i'm sure i'm sure they don't sell it
anymore it came in like this little
little brown bottle like this big little
cap on it and it was cough syrup
you know it's not soda
i [ __ ] loved the taste of that and uh
sometimes i would drink it when i didn't
have a cold not gonna lie just because i
liked the taste of it it was kind of
thick
and it kind of tasted like
cherry root beer is what it kind of
tasted like to me
and but but kind of thick
one time i loved it so much that one
time i drank almost a whole bottle and
uh barfed my guts out so yeah sergeant
rocco's in there i guess he's an
ex-soviet citizen he's talking about
they didn't really have sodas in the
soviet union
they just had um
sparkling water and it had sodas to it
that's actually what a lot of
that's a lot of soft drinks were that
for a long time coca-cola and dr pepper
and some of the other ones came
pre-mixed they were like patented
medicines
but when you went to places like soda
fountains they made you a soda that way
that same way
you can make a custom soda like that so
we had that also just that it didn't
stay around long
by the time
by the time the 60s came around they
were gone yeah that was kind of more of
a thing like in the 50s i feel like the
50s was like a big thing where you had
like the end of it yeah where you had
like soda jerks you would go to these
like little diners and stuff and they'd
make you
you know like like a thing or you know
they'd make you something like up in the
northeast they make you like egg creams
which is kind of like a chocolate soda
type of thing with yeah it was like
chocolate malt and
seltzer water right yeah something like
that yeah they made it yeah different
ones but the 50s is kind of was the last
hurrah
by the time the 60s came around the big
corporations had replaced all that with
pre-canned sodas
and knocked all that [ __ ] out of
business
couldn't make money couldn't compete
against them and then it'd be this by
the time the 60s came around it was fast
food like mcdonald's and all that
started to come about
um
but i think all that making your own
private sodas
went back into the 1800s
because if i remember correctly
um they were there were episodes of the
little rascals taking place in the 1930s
where they go to those places and they
make them a soda
remember yeah so they were doing that
yeah that was a big thing although like
i said insurgent rock i just brought
this up because i was going to say
something about that yeah people are
starting to do that now because now you
can get something called a soda stream
which essentially you can make your own
it carbonates water you can put your own
[ __ ] flavors and stuff in it so you
can make your own [ __ ] now sergeant
rocklin says there's a russian soda
that's neon green and it's called tarkun
it's really good but it's an acquired
taste
it's tarragon flavored oh
[ __ ]
tarragon i mean nothing wrong with
tarragon
yeah but uh
in certain applications
all right then i'm not sure how i would
feel about that it might be good i don't
know all right sorry it sounds weird but
that is okay that's the russian version
of root beer
if you get american root beer
or if you want to go even above that you
go to the [ __ ] sarsaparilla
sarsaparillas the old school root beer
yeah
it's a drink like that it's brown like
coca-cola carbonated
but it's sassafras root and sugar yeah
and
some people say it tastes like medicine
most foreigners don't like it a lot of
americans love it i love it
but we were grow we grew up on it it's a
very sweet and herbal flavor
kind of like a niece
yeah kind of maybe root beer is like
more of like an older person
yeah it's like you've ever had anise
which is like the lick black licorice
flavor it's kind of like that but it's
not black licorice it's not hot it's
mild but it's on that same kind of
spectrum in a weird way if you can find
root beer you tell me what you you tell
me what you think of root beer i don't
know if you're in the united states or
what and i don't usually like things
that are flavored like a nice flavor
like i'm not super into like absinthe or
anything like that but i really do like
root beer yeah and then um grantha's
hammer he's a michigan boy we kind of
grew up together
if you guys don't know him um new to the
show he's we and him went to high school
together he's a retired policeman
he was talking about
um
faygo which is kind of like the state
brand yeah michigan all right faygo that
makes me think of insane clown yeah he
says
[Laughter]
nsa clown posse uses um red pop to
red pop is the one that they uh spray on
the ground yeah yeah um i liked all
faygo was funny because
when we were kids you could get an
entire two liter of fago i think for 50
cents
yeah that sounds about right you can get
it down here too you could get a two
liter from the same price as a [ __ ]
bottle
so it didn't matter
uh sometimes you could get sales or you
could get two of them for 50 cents like
a quarter they were trying to get rid of
[ __ ]
most of the flavors were they ranged
from okay to [ __ ] terrible
the worst one was one called arctic sun
god it was blue and it was
mint and orange i think i think it was
what it's supposed to be [ __ ] it [ __ ]
was terrible i like both of those
flavors but not together
i don't know
actually maybe it was me granters might
remember it
better than me it might have been mint
and grapefruit
again i like both of those flavors but
not together
and it was blue and they had a picture
of a glacier on it
uh the root their root beer was mediocre
a lot of stuff was mediocre the red pop
is pretty good i liked it which was just
red flavor red with a slight cream soda
flavor well that artificial red flavor
is a distinctive flavor all its own we
were talking about this the other day
because
i was talking about like a lot of things
that you know purport to be strawberry
flavored or cherry flavored are actually
not flavored like either of those real
things but are just a generic red flavor
but there's nothing wrong with that but
that's like an artificial flavor
xanada says tom how can you love a niece
but not like jagermeister you do like i
do like jagermeister i don't like
jagermeister
um you know what i mean he likes it
though yeah
um yeah uh sandra says oh man we don't
have root beer here
but i drank it when i was in canada and
i love it yeah it's good
filbert grimm says if you like root beer
you'd like sarsaparilla it's even better
yeah can you get a treat down in florida
uh
i guess not well i don't think so i've
never seen that
it's a soda
hmm
i just probably not yeah it's orange and
mint
anybody that's ever brushed their teeth
before breakfast and then drank orange
juice and realized
what a mistake they had made
we'll know that those two flavors do not
go together
so i'm just saying sergeant rocco says
my family in europe who tried root beer
despise it yeah i kind of feel like a
lot of europeans don't like it um
i don't know if he likes it or not would
you like it
does anyone make sarsaparilla that maybe
i'm probably i'm sure they're going to
be oh yes it's like crosstalking
sarsaparilla if you've had verners
that's a that's kind of like that's
ginger ale yeah this is ginger ale yeah
i love ginger ale yeah i don't like
ginger beer though
ginger beer i'm gonna get another i'm
gonna get beer actually
yeah bring me one or two or whatever
okay yeah well you know just so you
don't have to get up again um
i really like ginger ale burners uh
canada dry sea grams all that shit's
good
but
i don't really like ginger beer all that
much it's just too spicy for me it's
hard to get um i know in the uk like
there's ginger beer everywhere
and some of it was pretty good
in the u.s
um
at least when i was looking because my
ex-husband like [ __ ] loved ginger
beer so we would always go looking for
it in the u.s at least back then it was
much easier only to get like jamaican
ginger beer and the jamaican ginger beer
is like much hotter
than the uk ginger beer or at least
certain uh you know brands of it
and i would find ginger ale does not do
this
but if i drink jamaican ginger beer
the second i drink it i start sneezing
and i can't stop
so it's like
it's just
like any like any kind of too hot ginger
beer is like too hot for me but i like
ginger ale though and i like like weaker
ginger beer
but we even tried to make our own ginger
beer
uh
in the bedroom closet like so we had big
jars of it
we never could get it
i don't know it never exploded or
anything like that but it's just like it
was never as good
so we just kind of gave up on it
after a while
um yeah non-fornix says i prefer ginger
beer to ginger ale i know a lot of
people do like i like i said it just
i don't know ginger beer it just it's
too hot it's too much for me it's just
like it gets all up in my sinuses and
starts making me sneeze
um you know so but i like ginger ale
though
uh yeah root beer
mug is my favorite they're all good
um
i don't know i don't know which one's my
favorite brand
and w's good they're all pretty good
honestly i don't drink it enough to
know one brand from the other
but
you know they're all pretty good like i
said i'm not a big soda fan
for a while like tom likes soda
so sometimes we go to win dixie and we'd
get their
uh they're kind of like cheapy brand
would uh check
c-h-e-k
and they'd have [ __ ] like you know
strawberry soda which i liked orange
soda
so i would get [ __ ] like that
he likes cream soda which i don't
but
i don't know i just found myself not
really like drinking it i don't reach
for it
honestly when i'm in here if i'm not
drinking alcohol
pretty much the only thing i drink thank
you
is water
you know
we have the thing in our fridge that has
changed
you gonna change hats yeah entertain the
people for a second i gotta i made a big
old pot of hungarian food today i was
gonna say
yeah [ __ ] it's so good i got a lot of it
chicken paprikash
took uh i had a whole bunch of um
chicken thighs
with uh and then chicken drumsticks
a whole bunch of them they got them
cheap
so i put them in a pan brown
didn't cook them all the way through
just seared them
put them aside
put a bunch of onions in there fried up
the onions put some red peppers in there
and did that
um
let's see what it has put some more had
some oil in there and some chicken
chicken drippings from the you know from
the searing the chicken
and then i put
paprika a lot of it sweet paprika
put that in there
put some then i put the then put some
chicken stock in it
um then i took all that and i poured
that on top of the chicken put that in
the pot
slow cooked it
like almost two hours real low
like falling off the bone i took a bunch
of sour cream and then whole cream
and flour mixed it up dropped it all in
there to thicken it
let it cook for another half hour
[ __ ] man that [ __ ] was so good damn
you're supposed to serve it with like
egg noodles
but i like it on mashed potatoes
so i served it on mashed potatoes
we got a super chat
from zach zach sent me five dollars
thank you zach says i've recently
discovered mint choco chip ice cream
with some scoops of peanut butter with
peanut or almond butter it's a beautiful
flavor okay honestly i'm gonna have to
turn that out yeah don't don't tell
don't tell uh sandra don't tell me
because i'll like gain 300 pounds on
that [ __ ] because those are all my
favorite flavors all in one place yeah
mint and chocolate and almonds are my
favorite peanut butter does belong in
ice cream
it does peanut butter vanilla ice cream
melt the peanut butter a little bit pour
it over there like hot fudge i honestly
i would rather have
hot peanut butter on vanilla ice cream
than hot fudge you could just take
peanut butter
vanilla ice cream
a little bit of milk and a banana and
blend it
man [ __ ] the banana though yeah banana
well you don't need the banana but yeah
i don't need the banana
we were talking about that the other day
because i said honestly
um
as much as i love chocolate which i do
but i've never been a big hot fudge fan
yeah like on ice cream or something like
that it's a little much
for me i'm making sergeant rocco hungry
like if i'm gonna eat ice cream with
like something on it i would rather have
caramel or peanut butter yeah um and i
want something crunchy in there like i
said i want
you know i want nuts in it too
yeah sondra we got this thing where we
take
a big mug like a big beer mug like a
stein
take you a german stein
a clear glass one
put a scoop of ice cream maybe two
scoops of ice cream then slowly pour
root beer in there it's called a root
beer float if you like root beer you'll
like those two again just eat it with a
spoon and drink it oh yeah root beer
flutter
beer floats are super good
well that was i kind of feel like it a w
a and w when they first started out like
now i'm not talking about the brand i'm
talking about like the the restaurant
when they first started out
that's kind of what they were known for
was root beer floats right hi pokey
oh i was gonna say she came back in when
i was in the bathroom i guess
xander said i sent a photo of my pb and
j to my friend in the philippines and
she said that looks disgusting only
americans eat peanut butter
ridiculous they don't though yeah thai
people eat peanut butter they make like
a peanut butter like you know
satay or whatever they call it
that's peanut butter that's peanut
butter essentially
um you know same thing who said this
dana
said that okay chocolate peanut butter
ice cream
yeah i eat that honestly
i really like i think we had the publix
brand of this like one time a long time
ago we don't buy a lot of ice cream but
we got like some it was vanilla ice
cream and it had little bitty
chocolate peanut butter cups in it yeah
oh man that was from really good reese's
peanut butter cups yeah like little
reese's peanut butter cups but off brand
reese's pig because it wasn't reese's
branded i don't know if sandra knows
about reese's peanut butter cups maybe i
think i told her
did they sell those over there i don't
know if they have them in germany
we got this candy here
it's called a reese's peanut butter cup
cassandra
and it comes in a little paper cup
brown well there's two of them like two
oven
and it's a chocolate shell and in the
middle of its peanut butter but it's
peanut butter and sugar it's not gooey
it's
salt connoisseur it's denser it's dense
it's kind of there's no way to describe
it so it changes it yeah it holds
together yeah and then they're they're
uh
that is easily easily one of the most uh
popular american candy what you can do
with those is freeze them
and when they come out frozen you crack
them break them into pieces and put that
into ice cream stir it stir it and or
sprinkle it
you can either sprinkle it on top of ice
cream you can stir it into ice cream or
you can
make a
vanilla
um shake
all right and then at the end add pieces
of
well dairy queen does a blizzard yeah uh
you can get a blizzard with yeah with
frozen reese's peanuts frozen reese's
peanut butter cups because you can get
mini ones too yeah
yeah but if you're going to make frozen
if you're going to make frozen reese's
powdered buttercups you just want to
freeze them if you're going to make a
blizzard it's it's it's frozen big ones
broken into pieces yeah in the shards
i mean i kind of feel like i was
watching uh company man the other day
which is another good youtube channel
and he did a video on dairy queen a few
days ago and he was talking about how
the blizzard
was kind of like their
and
you know as far as i know they're still
doing good nowadays but it's i feel like
the blizzard was like their
that was like the platonic ideal
of their menu yeah people still go i'm
if you don't know it's like it's kind of
like whipped ice cream with like and you
can have like crunched up frozen yeah
candy bars are very and they have a ton
of they have m ms they have heath bars
they have oreo cookies they have all
different kind of [ __ ] you can put in
there and it's like they're really
really [ __ ] good sandra says that
german peanut butter online shop has
everything from reese's though yeah when
you get those peanut butter cups you
only want reese's
i've never had
a knockoff
peanut butter cup
that tastes like reese's reese's can i
say though that
as far as chocolate to like the ratio of
chocolate to peanut butter
i kind of feel like the mini
ones the mini ones are better
i like the big ones i mean the big ones
are good too i'm not saying that the
only thing that ever
came close
was when i was living in boston
in harvard square
they had a candy shop that made candy
and they made
homemade peanut butter cups oh yeah in a
bunch of different flavors and they were
about the half the size of an apple they
were about that big around about that
tall they're about five bucks and they
were worth it they were really good the
peanut butter filling in the middle was
real close
real similar to a reese's filling
it had about that same texture
but it tasted even better
the secret is the texture other brands
can't quite get the texture right it's
moist but it's also kind of flaky
it falls apart you'll see
yeah it's not peanut butter for texture
xanada someone after my own heart reeses
with white chocolate though mm-hmm yeah
honestly
i know some people are grossed out by
white chocolate i [ __ ] love white
chocolate yeah i was the weirdo that
every easter
i just like i don't want regular
chocolate bunny i want a white chocolate
bunny so i was the only one that got
white chocolate bunny because i [ __ ]
love white chocolate yeah i love the
white chocolate kitkat
i love the white chocolate reese's i
love zero bars
so that's always exciting when you can
find those
they don't make a lot of
dedicated white chocolate sergeant rocco
tell me to try the aldi peanut butter
cups they're probably pretty good
everything i've gotten from aldi's
pretty good yeah it's european stuff i
got some one i got some uh white
chocolate peanut butter cups from
[ __ ] man i don't remember what brand it
was it was one of those you know how um
sometimes at schools they'd give you
like they'd make the kids like sell the
[ __ ] from like a mail order type of
thing and i got some white chocolate
peanut butter cups from one of those
from like a work you know a work
colleagues kid or something and that
[ __ ] was pretty delicious too so i kind
of feel like you know there's good ones
out there it's not just reese's reese's
makes other [ __ ] too like every holiday
they make
um
they'll make like uh like little
pumpkins with peanut butter in the
middle
little witches with peanut butter and
metal ghost [ __ ] like that they make a
little christmas tree [ __ ] like that so
like every holiday they make sandra said
that she also ate
uh root beer wine gums in canada they
were awesome i don't know what a wine
gum is it must be like a chew i've heard
that phrase but i'm not i can't really
place where i heard it before here in
the united states the traditional root
beer candy is a thing called a root beer
barrel oh yeah and it looks like a beer
barrel that tall made out of total sugar
it's a hard candy like a jolly rancher
and it's wrapped in plastic in in clear
plastic paper
and you can get a bunch of them for
they're cheap real cheap
and they have that real strong root beer
flavor and if you can find those try
those that's an american classic i used
to give them out from halloween i used
to love them the root beer barrels
honestly um you know those candies like
the bottle caps yeah uh the root beer
flavor of the bottle cap is the only
flavor that's worth eating yeah so we
would get bottle caps when we were
growing up at halloween and they came
like three in a packet and you'd open
them and i would take all the root beer
ones out and then like throw the other
ones away yeah i didn't like the other
flavors uh thank you zach he says jenny
did you ever work for the girl scout
cookie extortion mafia yes i did which
was your favorite if so thin mints i
mean i don't know anybody says that all
right ryko he says seriously jenny and
tom i'd love to send you some buckeyes
and ohio pbj chocolate especially do you
have a p.o box here's the thing
accepting food from total strangers
online is kind of dangerous are you
going to poison us
unless it's totally factory sealed
um yeah i mean it has to be something
totally factory sealed but yeah we have
we have it uh we have
you can contact jenny
um on facebook or instagram or patreon
or whatever and i can give you we don't
have a p.o box but i'll send people home
address right y'all aren't going to
stalk us you better not yeah i mean
tom's armed so
[Laughter]
you know what i'm saying i stopped you
that was my [ __ ] job all right
i stalk you
we're not cool we're not cool enough for
anybody
if they have put me on you it's because
they want something bad happen to you
okay i'm not worried about stalkers
i'm not either really no and honestly
i've been asked about that like on
because i write about a lot of true
crime and stuff and i've been asked it's
like do you
since you write about like some murders
that might still be alive do you worry
they're coming after you i'm like well
i don't know the chances of that
happening are pretty slim gotta say
uh i got a lot more [ __ ] i gotta worry
about see you know of all the things
yeah i mean honestly
i i kind of feel like can anybody really
i know that there's some people that
don't like mint
but of all the girl scout cookies
i mean thin mints
are kind of like
the best ones and especially if they're
frozen
um although i will say that if it's not
girl scout cookie time
um
you can get what are those uh
keebler cookies called i think they're
called grasshoppers and they taste uh
exactly the same
so you know what i mean they're a little
bit thicker and they're square they're
not round but okay okay same flavor a
wine gum
it's not a chewing gum but a soft gum
like something from harborough it's a
gummy bear called a gummy yeah yeah i
know what you're talking about yeah the
root beer gummies are good
um
you you'd like the root beer barrel the
traditional root beer barrel try to find
those
they're hard it's a hard candy
in plastic
clear plastic they'll come in a big bag
they're cheap
and it's kind of like a
it's like a little you know the
lollipops they're like that but doesn't
have a sticker it doesn't have a handle
on it
and it's um if you get a good brand
they're got a real good flavor just put
them in your mouth and it's kind of like
a like a ricola or something
recall yeah
that's what i tell you that's a cough
drop in case yeah or whatever
well the thing is is that
the real good ones are aromatic like
yeah
um although i'll tell you one thing
americans do not know what good black
licorice tastes like european black
licorice like up in scandinavia is like
eating a piece of fine meat it's real
chewy
fantastic flavor man super super
aromatic i love
scandinavian black licorice man that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] good man really good
i'm not a big
food man it's like a food it's not like
candy i mean i'll eat it i don't hate it
but it's not my favorite thing
we've kind of talked about this before
where
you're more of like a fruity candy dude
and i'm more of like a nutty
chocolate candy person
sergeant rock i said it will be factory
sealed okay just contact her on facebook
yeah and i'll just give you like i said
i can give you the home address
oh i poured that like an [ __ ] you
poured it like an [ __ ] now you gotta
drink it like an [ __ ] it's all foam
no i'll wait until it's all right it's
okay i'm patient
i'm patient
yeah i'm not i i don't know i don't like
i don't like licorice
i don't like twizzlers if i'm gonna like
i said it's one of those things where
i've gotten to the age now where
you know
i have to watch the calories
so if i'm gonna eat something sweet if
i'm gonna eat something desserty like
candy or cake or something like that
it's gotta be something i really really
like i don't really wanna waste
300 500 700 calories on something that's
just like mediocre you know what i mean
i want something really really really
really good
that's all i'm saying um
santa's talking about saltwater taffy
that's another one
sandra
i bought you a five pound bag of salt
water taffy for your birthday we have to
we have this
we have this stuff here in america
called saltwater taffy
it's been around for over a hundred
years
it's a candy
it's chewy
it's handmade it's kind of like kind of
like a starburst candy there's no way to
describe it
they make it
and they roll it out and then they slice
it and there's stuff
braided into it so they can make
patterns
and it's
very chewy
but it dissolves as you chew it
and there's a bunch of different flavors
like cream flavors
apple
black licorice
watermelon i mean you can very much make
anything peanut butter they got peanut
butter salt water i do like that one i
like the vanilla peanut butter i like
that kind of i don't really like the
fruity flavor so much you can get it
online you can peppermint the pepper
peppermint too you can't buy it in
stores anymore it's too old-school well
it's hard to get it's hard to get yeah
it has to be made on old-fashioned
machinery or it has to be made by hand
but you can get it online it's called
salt water taffy remember i sent you
that picture i was in st augustine yeah
in the you know in the big touristy
historic part of saint augustine there's
a whole shop
that's all
taffy yeah
they make their own taffy from scratch
each little piece
comes wrapped in wax paper
and then you'll get a big clear bet or
you'll get a box when you order it it'll
come in a big cardboard box and you open
it up and there's a big plastic bag
like a zip lock and you open it up and
in there's all these
pieces of candy wrapped in wax paper
they're fantastic some of these
companies
will sell an assortment
other companies you can tell them what
flavors you want in there if you want
peanut butter and it's white cream with
a peanut butter man it's really good
really good but i would recommend an
assortment for your first time
because even
the even the peppermint ones are good
honestly i'm really into the peppermint
ones chewy and then you swallow it
mandy nicole says real saltwater taffy
is so stinking good yeah in florida it's
not too there's a lot of like saltwater
taffy shops around here because it's
kind of a florida thing um he's she says
here in pompano beach which is down in
south florida we have a bunch of shops
here and like i said in st augustine
they there's at least one saltwater
taffy shop because i sent you a picture
of it it's addictive it's very addictive
and even though that's not my favorite
type of candy but like the pep like i
bought you that big huge bag of it that
one year and um but the peppermint one
was really good and the peanut butter
one's good they have a chocolate one
sandra says glad i don't live with tom
and jenny i would weigh 200 pounds yeah
yeah yeah it's really hard not to gain
weight around here and i try not to like
eat all that much but yeah it's hard
we don't buy
a lot of junk food no
we don't like i'm talking about it i
start wanting it yeah we don't i mean i
don't buy candy i don't
even know i'm in the grocery store i
don't we don't buy candy or cake or
anything like that because bro i will
eat a whole [ __ ] bag yeah that's the
problem
the problem with salt water taffy is
when you start you have a [ __ ] five
pound bag
and it's very difficult to stop ask
zanata that's a skinny little
[ __ ] it's very difficult to stop
eating it you just wanna oh man oh man
and it's and it's
some of the new stuff kind of has a
slightly artificial flavor the flavors
are a little more powerful
than
nature will allow but they're still
really good
the old school stuff was a little milder
flavors because they're using
old-fashioned flavorings it's both good
it's both good though
i i can't really
choose some people like the new
taffy's some people like the old taffy's
it just depends on what you're into
yeah i mean it depends on the and xanada
said the only one i don't like is banana
flavor i don't like bananas i like that
one though i don't like banana flavor in
anything honestly i'm not a big fan of
bananas
like natural bananas yeah and i really
don't like anything that's artificially
banana flavored that's just like one of
the grossest things dogs are googled and
she says we have something similar here
too it's called soft toffees yeah so
it's similar yeah and honestly like
sometimes i don't even think they call
this saltwater taffy do you remember
back in the old days i don't remember if
they sell these anymore but you know
what halloween
yeah sometimes if you went to like some
uh you know cheap [ __ ] house
they would put in your bag
these candies and i'm not judging
because i liked these
but they were essentially it was like
taffy but one of them was wrapped in
orange and one of them was wrapped in
black and they were
what flavor were they supposed to be i
don't understa i don't know if they were
supposed to be like peanut butter
flavored if they were like honey
flavored maybe it was like a bit of
honey but kind of softer do you know
what i'm talking about
yeah
so um you know they're good but they
came in like that real cheap
like five dollar
variety bag that also had like those
[ __ ] it was cheap ass lollipops and
stuff kind of like a chicken stick
yeah remember the chicken stick yeah it
was a weird thing
i don't think they make those anymore
yeah no they actually make all those old
candies still there's a company that
bought all of them oh yeah that's right
and uh somebody still makes those
[ __ ]
echo waivers necco wafers to make all
those why would you even bother
it's a retro experience thank you zach
but one uh one company owns all those
ancient companies and they make it's
like novelty old-fashioned candies
remember the little ones that had the
little babies
they were little brown babies they got
little mummies remember those things and
you chew them they were real chewy
wait i'm chewing on they're like little
babies they were brown flavored i forgot
they were called brown flavor
and they were brown
they were they looked like little babies
and they were brown
i think i know what you're talking about
but i don't think i ever had them though
it didn't they were they were babies but
they were shaped more like an egyptian
sarcophagus okay
i think i think i know you're talking
about
sugar babies
oh yeah yeah yeah they're called sugar
babies oh yeah i know you're talking
about yeah they were good too i remember
those those were old cans i don't think
i ever bought those because i was like
wow they were good
they're real good thank you zach it kind
of tasted like he says the biggest
things i have trouble not killing in one
sitting is peanut butter ooh peanut
bread yeah i once i haven't had peanut
butter in a long time yeah and beef it's
easy to make
yeah i've made it before yeah i made it
in school
and beef jerky i'm not a big fan of beef
jerky
you can actually if you look online
i didn't include this in the recipe book
maybe i should have
pretty much all of the american famous
mars and m m's candy bars you can make
those at home on a sheet pan
it won't look the same you just do it in
layers it's a lot easier to make it in a
big sheet pan
and cut it them out
so you won't have chocolate go down the
side but
you can make we just make oh henry bars
god they were good and the sheet pan
um
hundred thousand dollar bars remember
those
with the [ __ ] rice krispies yeah like
a hundred grand i think they are called
yeah 100 but they call them now
you can make them in a sheet pan
uh pretty quickly and and they come out
and you got you you get yourself [ __ ]
fat
you can even make um
uh snicker bars
you can make them in a sheet pan
the uh snickers bars are also super good
frozen yeah and i will say too that the
snickers ice cream bars are fantastic
right i love that [ __ ]
um but yeah snickers bars i
honestly if i'm gonna eat a candy bar
like i said it's gonna be something with
nuts or peanut butter or something
crunchy in it you know what i mean i
like crunchy
[ __ ] with nuts in it or like a twix that
has a cookie in the middle i don't
really like just ones that are kind of
plain yeah you see xana is telling me i
said chico sticks are still super
popular in california southern
california yeah dude i was naming some
[ __ ] i was blowing i was blowing [ __ ]
um
khan of arslan's mind all right
uh bringing up old mexican candies that
i grew up with in southern california
[ __ ] that he forgot about mexican
candies from the 70s you see
long beach california back in the 70s
was a heavy mexican influence
every little
every little dime store
or what they call liquor stores back in
the days they did have beer and some
liquor but it was mostly about
selling kids candy and comic books and
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that you know what i
mean we'd go in there and we would buy
up all the [ __ ] candy you know it was
like the little neighborhood store okay
yeah
well they had
american candy and then mexican stuff in
the same store and we we didn't give a
[ __ ] the mexicans mexican candies candy
and the mexican stuff was like half
price
okay because because of the peso
conversions and stuff so you could get a
lot of mexican candy
and
they had one candy that i remembered it
looked like it was like a lollipop all
right
but it's
it was a
like an umbrella like a cone about that
tall
okay that got skinny on the top
that was red white and green the mexican
colors and it was like oh i've seen
those yeah yeah yeah you could get like
i think there were only like maybe five
cents a piece you could get like a bunch
of them
okay the kids are buying them just
showing yeah yeah yeah yeah same time
another one it did another one that they
would give you was a piece of paper
with little buttons stuck to it and you
oh my god i used to love them remember
those yeah
they had mexican ones yeah uh yeah we
got those yeah well then well wasn't
there also uh mexican stoplight candy
yeah they had all kinds of mexican candy
yeah it was good and then i remember
that they had these weird mexican treats
that
were candy
but not in the american sense of what
candy was like salted prunes a bag of
salted prooms and you would just
challenge yourself eating these things
your mouth would all [ __ ] pucker up
and [ __ ] that's salty as [ __ ] then
you're like why do i have to poop
suddenly
they had to [ __ ] they had the [ __ ]
uh seeds in them and everything and
we're like here see if you can eat it
it's like a chow okay you know how these
kids are today eating those
warheads ultra sour or like booger
flavored jelly beans or vomit flavored
jelly beans like the harry potter ones
no that's not that's not what i'm
talking about
that's not what i'm talking about the
warhead like the super sour super super
sour [ __ ] like warheads okay where like
kids are
challenging each other can you eat that
all right well the mexicans had that
they had it they had that [ __ ] cornered
with these [ __ ] salted [ __ ] prunes
okay
see if you can hang on to your [ __ ]
[ __ ] eating that thing it's salty as
[ __ ]
you're like mouth-surfing you're taking
me like them
[Laughter]
looking at each other little kids you
know little boys
it was a challenge you know i mean you
prove that you're a man
eating that
and then another one that we used to get
was the mexican dried shrimp it'd be a
whole pack of these little bitty gold
shrimp they'd be dried down to nothing
they had the shell and all were just
eating them like popcorn they were good
they were really good i would eat that
yeah they were good and they were that
sounds delicious they were spicy too
honestly you could shake that [ __ ] over
like a thing of popcorn yeah that'd
probably be really good yeah
a little golf shirt next time we're at
the movies and they had the shell on
them and
everything it didn't matter crunchy
you're just crunchy just eat them you
can eat the sugar it's fine they didn't
weigh anything
and uh like you could get a big bag of
them for a quarter
back about that tall like that you're
sitting there see you're a kid you only
have like a few coins in your pocket you
gotta like maximize your they only gave
you a dollar sure yeah i know so you had
to buy as much as you could like i can
buy one jolly rancher
i can buy a whole bag of like these
weird like shrimpy things
the mexicans understood the game they
understood the gay they're like we got
to get that kid's dollar as much of that
kid's dollar now
what would lose out
is the mexicans would lose out to jolly
rancher
i mean watermelon jolly ranchers are
pretty much the best yeah ever
nowadays a jolly rancher is a little
cube wrapped in paper well they had
cubes they had the sticks
they had both when i was growing up when
i was a kid they did the little cubes
didn't come out yet it was just those
sticks
and man they would put you into a
[ __ ]
conundrum with those [ __ ] sticks
because you only had so much money they
were cheap they were like 10 cents each
for a stick maybe less
they'd have all of a man that have a
fire stick
and orange ones and [ __ ] grape ones
and watermelons and
green apple
and you you didn't know which one to get
because you only had so much so you
gotta stand there for like an hour yeah
so you're like a kid trying to do
advanced [ __ ] calculations in your
[ __ ] head
of which ones you can afford
and which one you're gonna sacrifice
i never got that grape one i was i never
liked the grape stick i don't really
like the reason i didn't like it it was
too sweet
and i don't mind some grape flavored
things but but the fire stick always had
always had me enthralled
watermelon yeah the watermelon cherry
and that green apple the watermelon and
the cherry were the best ones i don't
like green apple stuff i like that and
then they came out with and then i
remember when a new flavor came out and
my mind was [ __ ] blown as a kid
to understand the concept that a new
flavor could appear someone entered a
new flavor
and the flavor was peach
yeah i loved it
peach
they had a peach one again i'm not a
real i like peaches i'm not a big fan of
artificial peach flavor and i think they
had a
oh and then a lemon one they had a peach
one and a lemon okay now lemon i will
eat lemon [ __ ] all day long oh yeah
even if it's artificial real i don't get
it
lemon lime kind of flavor i'll eat that
[ __ ] all day long so there's like a
bunch of questions that we got behind on
yeah santa says
have you guys ever had or made puppy
chow yes but i don't think we call it
that down here but i know i know what
you're talking about um yeah i've made
that
um
or no bake cookies yeah um sergeant
rocco says i hate to have to leave it's
hard for me to catch you live but thank
you so much for the warm welcome i'll be
back thank you very much also later he
says today is my first day of retirement
damn congratulations who says this
sergeant rocco okay we'll hit patreon as
soon as my checks start and support you
thank you so much thank you very much
thank you seriously don't feel like you
have to but you know we appreciate it
obviously if you can and we'll send you
some mellie's buckeyes thank you very
much that's like awesome i'm looking
forward to that
so you know uh somebody also asked what
i feel like somebody else asked a
question and i missed it so which one
was puppy chow
uh that was also um that was canada yeah
but what is it i don't know it's kind of
like isn't it kind of like chex mix
i kind of feel like it's oh chex mix and
you mix all the [ __ ] together and then
you put worcestershire sauce in it and
mix it in it like that yeah yeah yeah
maybe maybe i'm thinking something i
think i think it's what you talk about
tammy says have you tried to take five
candy bar yes and they are [ __ ]
delicious
are they the ones i think they still
sell them yeah i think if this is what
i'm thinking of it's chocolate but it
also has
peanut butter and maybe pretzels and
cookie
so it's got like a crunchy element it's
got like a nutty element yeah
if it's the one i'm thinking of you
could say yeah it had that the little
umbrella it's called piruli
okay yeah okay yeah it was good we liked
them
i couldn't tell you what flavor it was
it was just sweet
i don't think the colors had different
flavors
if i remember correctly well do you
remember this one flavor you remember
those popsicles that they sold at the
ice cream truck yeah that were like the
red white and really like the rock the
bomb pops yeah um i kind of feel like
they were supposed to be different
flavors but they never really tasted
different to me they just tasted like
ice flavor
they i remember them tasting different
i think it was lemon cherry and grasalia
which is kind of like a berry flavor
i guess but i don't know they all kind
of like blended together the white one
was kind of like seven up
okay
yeah and the red one was like cherry
yeah i think they were different flavors
yeah i remember them being pretty good i
liked them
honestly if the ice cream truck came i
never got those my brother liked them
but um i usually got like the mickey
mouse bar or uh nutty buddies
you know the ice cream cone with the
nuts and the
hard chocolate on top camp guy says to
make a shot masala powder you can
sprinkle on vegetables and fries i have
some yeah
yeah we have some
um yeah you can also make that we're all
about indian food the indian food well
we have um pretty close to us
there are some really good uh asian
markets yeah
we have a really good asian market what
the [ __ ] is that place called spice
world spice spices spice land yeah
and it's pretty big yeah
and they have all they have refrigerated
section they have a produce section
everything
you can get pretty much anything you
want
mostly indian food but they have some
uh they have british candy and cookies
they have
thai food they have some chinese
and japanese stuff but it's mostly
indian stuff
um
the the can the the ice cream that i
used to get from the ice cream truck
wasn't the bomb pop
i used to like
the banana and um fudge one it was like
a bomb pop but it was brown and with a
yellow stripe in the middle remember
that one yeah i remember that that one
just get that one i never got that
[Laughter]
i think it was called a super fudge bomb
pop or something like that
and then the other one i used to get
was one called strawberry shortcake
okay i got that
yeah that one was good yeah and they
also had a chocolate version yeah i'm
getting that one too you can still get
that i think yeah strawberry shortcake
it was a it was a it's an ice cream bar
that had like a strawberry filling
a
white outer shell made out of cream it
was dipped in a red and white little
crumbles
it was cheap as [ __ ] a cheap ice cream
but it was just it was delicious can i
say when i was in the uk i don't know if
they sell them because some of you guys
are bread so you can tell me when i was
in the uk they had something called
a magnum
ice cream bar
and it was kind of like that but like a
thousand times better
it was like this really thick like
sumptuous
ice cream bar with like the hard
candy shell on the outside it was so so
good that's puppy chow i don't recognize
it okay so it's kind of like chex mix
with sort of
but it's not really like chex mix
because chex mix has like other [ __ ] in
it like looks like pretzels looks like
what was that [ __ ] and frosted mini
wheats is what it looks like sort of but
it looks like
it looks more like um rice chex but with
like covered [ __ ] on it
they had this other stuff
that was kind of like that you took
checks
chex cereal
a white one and a brown one there were
two different ones
with little pretzels nuts
no
marshmallows no
well you could if you wanted but i would
rather not certain spices that you put
in there i think it actually had cayenne
pepper
sprinkled into yeah if you wanted to
make it hot you could put that in there
and then you oh this weirdest [ __ ]
thing you took [ __ ] worcestershire
sauce yeah and [ __ ] sprinkled that in
there and then mixed it give it that
umami it was great absolutely great it
is good it looks like something you have
at the bar
because it's like salt like a salty
savory yeah it's good with like if
you're drinking beer right right real
good with alcohol
yeah somebody's like people are talking
about magnums i just thought i saw a
commercial
probably like a year or two ago that
they had started selling them in the us
and i was like really excited because i
remember like really liking them when i
was in the uk and they're really really
good
and i kind of feel like we didn't have
them before now but yeah they were super
good
um
yeah sandra says magnum ice is yummy
er dove makes magnum do they
because honestly like dove all their
[ __ ] is like really good they have those
like bags
of
they're kind of like they're just like
solid
you know milk chocolate they have solid
dark chocolate but they're like little
squares but they're like really good
they're like really
silky
you know what i mean yeah so those are
like really good
but um i wanted to say something else uh
not hornets i usually went with a choco
taco
those were good too honestly if i was
gonna get some from the ice cream truck
and this is like a long time ago
i would usually get
nutty buddy
and i'm i think they still sell those
there's another name for him too
uh what's the other name for him
[ __ ] i can't remember now but it's just
it's an ice cream cone
with ice cream but it has like hard
chocolate nuts but then it has hard
chocolate at the bottom
of the ice cream cone
like to keep it from leaking out the
bottom i don't remember that one the
[ __ ] is the name of that i don't know
but yeah i would usually get those
because like i said i like if i'm gonna
get like ice cream and [ __ ] i'm gonna
get nuts in it i don't remember much
about those little ice creams
from the 70s that's pretty much all i
would get or i would get like the ones
that looked like a mickey mouse face oh
i remember those oh they're most good
though
well
like i said i wasn't in a bomb pops i
didn't like the push-ups
i liked those i didn't like yeah yeah i
don't i don't like fruity ice cream yeah
usually
in paper yeah yeah you pulled the paper
top off and then you you peeled it it's
like wax paper to as you ate it you had
to peel the out you wrap it down
remember and then there's like they were
really good yeah they're really good
yeah they were good i like those a lot
and the cone on it was real crispy and
crunchy and real chewy i remember and it
had like a solid thing of chocolate at
the bottom that kept the ice cream from
leaking out i don't remember that which
like i said very very clever yeah
because it kept like the ice when the
ice cream started to melt
it wouldn't leak out the bottom because
it had that solid plug of like chocolate
at the bottom that was solidified which
was a good idea
but um yeah what was i saying oh
the only
fruity i don't like sherbet really
the only fruity ice cream i've ever
liked
is
that indian restaurant that we go to and
like mary memories of india that makes
their own mango ice cream yeah
which is
delicious even though i don't really i'm
not a big mango fan yeah i don't really
like mangoes that they taste perfumey
but
their mango ice cream is
amazing yeah
it's amazing tasting
it doesn't taste like mangoes it's some
kind of mix that they put in that
machine and put cream in there and it
comes out and it's not like soft serve
it's ice cream yeah and it's bright
orange
it's really good
the way indians make ice cream isn't
like ours it has a lot more ice in it
kind of more like a gelato
in a certain way yeah it's not as creamy
i don't think it's good though it's it's
their own way of doing it
grampa's hammer says how come the bubble
gum in bubble gum ice cream was like
chewing on pebbles
i don't remember honestly i wouldn't
know because i have never ever gotten
bubble gum ice cream my whole entire
life because that sounds [ __ ]
disgusting yeah he's talking about real
retro
[ __ ] basketball yeah when you used to
go to yeah we in our mall we used to
have a baskin robbins and you i never
got that flavor though because that
sounded like gross i had it i had it it
was good it wasn't real bubble gum i
don't think it was meant to be a bubble
gum you could swallow
you couldn't chew it blow bubbles with
it
um
there was a
carvel and carvel's ice cream was kind
of even lower budget and cheaper than
the old baskin robbins new baskin
robbins is nowhere near as bad as it
used to be
there's something about
ice cream has moved up a bit since the
70s they had some funky ass ice cream
i remember how artificially how
artificial tasting carvilles used to
taste
they had a whole bunch of [ __ ] fruit
flavors i loved them as a kid but
looking back on them that [ __ ] was
bright blue ice cream and bright red ice
cream
and they had kind of a
funny taste and i remember that adults
wouldn't eat it they're like nice
but
carvel's kind of had a weird artificial
flavor to it
uh i think i remember one guy saying
like oh you can taste the dye in that
sometimes you could yeah i couldn't as a
kid but
as a kid you're kind of like tolerant to
stuff there's something about the
texture i don't remember if you guys
remember carvilles from the 70s it was
weird
it's always getting weird [ __ ] like
blueberry ice cream and stuff i mostly
remember carvel because i don't think we
had a carvel store where i grew up but
you um you saw the ads for like the ice
cream cakes
yeah for people's birthdays those didn't
taste all that good either i never had
one i love ice cream cake but i never
had one from carville it's probably
better than like fudgy the whale and all
that it's probably a lot better than it
was i mean people's people's tolerance
is not what it is yeah you can't really
compete with shitty crap anymore like he
used to be able to i do remember old
baskin-robbins from the 70s though man
is looking my one of my two my favorite
flavors that they [ __ ] made was black
licorice man that [ __ ] was good and they
had that during halloween and then then
they had the pumpkin one
for for thanksgiving
pumpkin ice cream pumpkin ice cream it
was pumpkin pie ice cream
oh yeah see now that's something i could
get behind it was [ __ ] great
i'm sure they probably sell that
nowadays because they have pumpkin spice
everything yeah now
and i'm sure
i bet even publix has a pumpkin pie ice
cream around around halloween or
thanksgiving that probably has like bits
of like
uh crust black pie
black licorice ice cream was jet black
i mean that sounds nasty oh it was jet
black high gloss jet black it looked
like obsidian
it looked like [ __ ]
no it looked like coke have you ever
seen coke yeah which is a piece of coal
that's shiny yeah yeah like it's almost
obscenic like it it looked like coke
and that's how [ __ ] black and
glistening it looked
it would make all your inside your mouth
black
it tastes great though
i
haven't had in a long time but looking
it was funny it shouldn't be melting all
that black stuff could be melted
adults would look at your side then the
inside of your toilet used to be like i
wouldn't eat that you know
but well [ __ ] even they had taste back
then yeah even though they didn't know
what our names did i remember i remember
being delicious i remember like we had a
baskin robbins in our mall in daytona
when i was little
hold on the grand theft auto
grandparents and he says let's be honest
though red velvet cake is disgusting you
shut up go ahead and check off i love
red velvet it's not my favorite but i i
actually do really like the cake
yeah i've made bread velvet cake on many
occasions tomato sauce
in there
you know that right has tomato sauce in
there
well you can make a really good um
chocolate cake with ketchup or tomato
paste tomato paste it sounds [ __ ] up
but it doesn't taste like tomato it
really doesn't
the flavor it just makes it like super
moist and like
it gives it that like umami
yeah kind of flavor
there are a lot of look like look it up
there are a lot of like chocolate cake
recipes that have ketchup
like or
tomato paste in them
it sounds nasty but it's actually like
really really good seriously
take my word for it
no i like red velvet
like i said it's not my favorite
but
i'll eat it they're going red velvet
does suck red velvet does not suck
you're just getting a sucky red velvet
cake good relevant red velvet cake with
[ __ ]
yeah
yeah it has to have like the white
honestly though like red velvet cake
i've never known like what
flavor is it though exactly
red flavor it's kind of like it's kind
of chocolate it's kind of like chocolate
but it's more like
it's not even like a malty chocolate
it's like a i think it's chocolate
it is but i had to go back and look at
it
i'm not sure what it is i haven't made
one a long time and when i did make it
was made it out of a mix but you can
[ __ ] put tomato sauce in it
and it'll give it a
richer color and a better texture
and um no
no y'all are tripping you're you're not
getting good red velvet cake well i mean
some people just might not like it
you know on on the other side of that
i'm not gonna get all like [ __ ] you
gotta make the right frosting for it
it's gonna be that white cream frosting
man it's just looking good dude i mean
i'll eat pretty much any kind of cake or
pie or anything i'm not picky you eat it
with a scoop of ice cream yeah it's not
like i said it's not my favorite
um
i don't even know what my favorite cake
is there's so many
but
you know when i was growing up when i
was a little kid every time it was my
birthday when i was little
and my mom or my grandma or whoever was
making the cake would always ask what
kind of cake i wanted you know what kind
of cake i wanted for like years and
years marble yeah like you know marbled
like vanilla and chocolate
for whatever reason that was like my
favorite
because i didn't like just plain
chocolate cake because it was too much
chocolate i don't like it
but i was like well just plain vanilla
seems too boring
so i liked like the combination of the
two things
even nowadays
i don't know
i'll eat chocolate cake but
it's not my first choice i would rather
vanilla or
you know some something like that how
long we've been how long have been
rolling three hours and 20. okay we need
to start thinking about shutting it down
in a bit we've been on for three
hours xanada says new york style
cheesecake over red velvet cake well
yeah yeah yeah i mean
new york style cheesecake take over
anything cheesecake pretty much wins
over yeah anything
you can't compare cake with cheesecake
yeah they're two different things two
different things
do you remember like back i don't know
if they still sell this nowadays but
when i was uh growing up
my
grandma for christmas
would always go to sam's
and she would get they used to sell like
a cheesecake but it was like
six different flavors there were like
two slices of cheesecake each
but it's like one of them was like had
strawberries on it one of them was like
chocolate
nut yeah that's what i thought oh yeah
but it's like that's when i was a kid
yeah
um and man what you're doing
all of those were good she's she wants
to go back up yeah actually sam sells
those yeah that's well that's where she
got it that's where she got it yeah like
a variety cheesecake yeah we'd always
get that like at christmas and that was
like super good man i love [ __ ]
cheesecake all kind of cheesecake is
good
like i said all kind of dessert is good
i have to stop myself from eating that
[ __ ]
because it's like so good although i
have to say one of my favorite things
and like i said this is reminding me
again of my grandma
because another thing she used to buy me
at christmas time
because for some reason i'm super into
these is petty fours
i love
petty fours of all kinds
um not a big fan of the chocolate ones
because i know they do um
what's that store that comes in the mall
every year uh hickory farms oh yeah they
do the store that's they do the box
that's all chocolate ones i'll eat those
but it's not my favorite i would rather
the vanilla cake ones with like the
different flavored frosting in the
middle
and the different flavored frosting on
the top
so you know like lemon mint whatever so
those are good so she would buy me a big
box of those every year for christmas
and
so a couple times because publix does
them like in their bakery
but they only sell
i think they sell like four
in a little clam shell
and it's kind of expensive but they're
really good i like those as well even
though it's essentially like cake but
it's just like bite size
you know yeah
yeah camp guys going to used to have a
hickory farms in every mall when i was a
kid yeah back when malls existed
yeah
well yeah i mean we didn't i don't think
it was there all the time but it would
usually spring up around christmas time
no most small no small most malls had
them forever
we well no i'm just talking about our
our mall in daytona which was a fairly
large mall but it would come
it would uh turn up like right after
halloween yeah and then it would just
sell [ __ ] for like christmas like it was
thanksgiving and christmas and some
sausages and cakes and [ __ ] like that in
a lot of the big malls um back here in
the [ __ ] mall heyday we're talking
70s and 80s
they were hickory farms was there all
year round
and it was um that's because back in
that old culture
that was a gift
people would give that [ __ ] as gifts
yeah cheese and [ __ ] cheese and
crackers yeah i used to give to my
brother or my dad because they love that
[ __ ] and it made sense because you
didn't know what to get this
[ __ ] i don't know what to get
this dude
or whatever everyone got to eat yeah
we'll give them some special this and
that no that that'll shut that [ __ ] up
i'll just put my name on it give him a
letter that's that's what that was all
about
and it worked
it was it was a good gift shop
and i've eaten a lot of stuff out of
there over the years yeah i have too and
it was all good
it was all good i even liked all the
sausages and like cheese and stuff
crackers yeah
and you couldn't go wrong because you're
giving somebody
a gift and you don't know what to get
them and you eat that
i mean as long as they're not a
vegetarian right yeah or a vegan or
something they didn't exist back in
those days well like i said
if they were a dude you could buy them a
big box of like sausages and cheese and
they'd be like that'd be all about it
yeah laying up in the bed with a beer
[ __ ] cutting that [ __ ] off with a
knife and eating it like that and
getting fat and that's just what you did
dipping it in the mustard mm-hmm it came
with mustard well yeah and like i said
and then they had like desserty ones too
because like i said they had kind of um
you know they had the petty fours yeah
and my grandma would get me a box of
those every year and i was super excited
about it because i [ __ ] love petty
you have that round thing and you open
it up and have all those cheeses
yeah remember that they're then they're
wrapped in [ __ ] foil yeah each one of
them like a block of cheese
price i also liked those but you put
that on crackers with the meat yeah it
was great
they have like about eight different
flavors of cheese in it like i said as
long as you're not a vegan yeah you
couldn't couldn't go wrong with that
gift as long as that person ate meat
as i said everything back in the days if
you were a vegan everyone you're [ __ ]
crazy vegan what vegetarian [ __ ] out of
here well in the 80s
in the 80s nobody knew what a vegan was
yeah you know what that was
some people some people were vegetarians
in the 80s and they were looked at crazy
but people looked at you like you were
some crazy like hippie tree
hugger yeah which is so funny i don't
even think they associated it with that
they thought you were in some kind of a
cult
[Laughter]
what are you in one of them where you
were scientologists were you only
calling them sex you don't eat meat were
you a jesus freak
they would think that you were a jesus
freak
which i i don't think people know what a
jesus freak anymore so these youngsters
go watch mandy that's what jesus freaks
were
camp guy says i think hickory farms is
mostly a catalog mail order now probably
yeah i kind of feel like
in our mall they didn't have a
storefront they would set up a kiosk in
the middle
and it was usually like right after
you know like after back to school or
after halloween whenever they started
doing like holiday [ __ ] because that was
when they made all their sales and then
they would disappear big malls when i
was a kid you'd have that hickory farms
that [ __ ] would be open all year round
and right across from it open all year
round would be seized
candies let me go in there and get some
[ __ ] boxes of candy remember that
i don't think we had one of those yeah
one of those no oh yeah we had z's candy
too we had like candy stores but we
didn't have we didn't have that one and
well the thing is it wasn't it was a
candy store but it was a gift store
you couldn't go in there and get a piece
of candy you need it and walk out it was
going to be boxes
gift boxes of candy yeah
the only thing that sees katie had that
you could buy and walk out with these
candy canes
flavored candy canes different flavors
remember those
yeah they had them in the little glass
jars
but they didn't really have anything
small that was ready to eat maybe a
couple little things up near the
register
it was
it was for gifts
which like i said it seems like
well that's why like food as long as
somebody's not a vegan or a vegetarian
or something food is always a good gift
uh because everybody got to eat
um you know so it's gonna give people
like cocoa or coffee or something like
that because pretty much everybody drink
coffee right except mormons the thing is
is that you didn't want to give the [ __ ]
seized candy to a [ __ ] girlfriend
you're trying to sell here give this to
your girlfriend she would [ __ ] slap
you in the face man getting that girl
fat
[Laughter]
thank you thank you oh [ __ ] that
motherfucker's trying to get me fat
uh well i do feel like that's better
than buying them
diet raids
well yeah all right there's a pack of a
so all right
so so let's do like a whole like uh a
chart of [ __ ] not to buy your girlfriend
don't buy a girlfriend well like right
well okay so i kind of feel like
fattening [ __ ] is maybe in the middle of
that yeah below that you don't want to
get them like [ __ ] that just implies
it's like
luxury
well because then you're like i was
going to say it's going to [ __ ] don't go
to the don't go to the gas station and
buy them like the rose that's like or
the underwear that's like
folded into like a rose or whatever do
they still sell those no i don't know do
they still sell them never heard of it i
guess you've never even heard of that do
you know what well at gas stations
look the 7-eleven that was behind that's
a hooker gift
well yeah that's what i'm saying that's
a crackhorse at the 7-eleven that was
behind my grandma's house
um i don't know if it was underwear but
they did have like these roses
that were kind of like
i don't know and then maybe it was kind
of like had kind of like a garter kind
of situation happening on it and they
were super cheap they were like a buck
or two and it was like right by the
counter so you're up there buying your
cigarettes and booze and
you know snacks or whatever you're just
like oh yeah let me get one of these for
my girlfriend
you're like white trash toothless
girlfriend that's like lives or whatever
so it's like yeah don't get one of those
um i kind of feel like buying [ __ ] like
unless she specifically asks for it
um don't buy your girlfriend or wife
like a vacuum cleaner yeah no tools or
an iron yeah yeah or something it's like
unless like i said unless they
specifically ask like they super want
one uh i would not advise that
um i kind of feel like buying them
something fattening maybe in the middle
of that
i don't know maybe in the middle but
i don't know
lingerie probably also not a real big
because that's more a gift for you isn't
it yeah
don't get girlfriend laundry it's not
really a gift for her no
just a pro tip yeah you can buy it just
don't give it as a gift
yeah i mean you can just buy it it's
like hey i saw this and i thought of you
yeah yeah so we're gonna we going down
tonight yeah it's gonna look that's well
that's fine yeah i'm just saying like
don't buy it for like a birthday like
hey it's a gift for you and she's like
no this is good for you really um isn't
it not really for me
all right jenny i'm getting tired let's
go ahead and shut this [ __ ] show down
oh and tammy says no exercise equipment
yeah yeah that's another thing that
might be taken uh really the wrong way
right here you're getting kind of fat i
could buy you a stationary body get on
this [ __ ] bike you fat [ __ ]
getting fat
oh my god yeah that sounds like some
[ __ ] you would do yeah
i'd be open about it though here i'm
gonna get this big ride smack fat off
god
what the [ __ ] is happening to you
i mean we're laughing we've been
together a long time i know i know
you're schtick i know you're stick at
this point
burn that [ __ ] off god
the funk the sink
you're like as big as a [ __ ] house at
this point
[Laughter]
i'm guessing i'm getting tired oh my god
hankster says uh laughing my ass off
again i'm here as soon as you're leaving
oh man come on
and like seriously though we've been
here for like three and a half three and
a half hours we're so drunk at this
point
and tired man we were we were sleepy
when we started the show well yeah
because i woke up at like 5 30 this
morning yeah i'm gonna lay up in the bed
we're gonna lay up in the bed i was
gonna lay up in the bed tomorrow we
don't have to work tomorrow do we all
right yeah we don't have to we don't do
the show tomorrow maybe yeah there's no
there's no live stream tomorrow i mean i
still have to work yeah i work every day
but you don't take off the day if you
want to shift
i can't though i have too much [ __ ] i
gotta do okay i can't ever take a day
off you don't understand i have too much
[ __ ] i got it i didn't get to ride today
i know i thought you told me you were
going to go ride me yeah there was so
much [ __ ] i was [ __ ] doing [ __ ]
watching [ __ ] watching [ __ ] on youtube
and [ __ ] catching up with people
social media dominates everything well
check out that [ __ ] i know i gotta
[ __ ] break away from that see that's
why i don't ever go on facebook yeah
i go there one time i'm talking and i
can't stop talking i go on there one
time a day and just check my [ __ ] and
i'm just like do i need to answer this
right now nope well then
i gotta i got [ __ ] i gotta do yeah and i
don't mean to be like offensive to
anybody but i got [ __ ] i gotta do just
say it all right jenny shut it down man
we've been we've been doing the show
all right i'm sorry hankster yeah but
seriously all right so
we'll be back on friday night somebody
asked us what our next uh true crime
case was gonna be friday night we're
gonna do a show about
and i'm kind of glad this got picked in
the poll
we're going to do a thing about the ken
mcelroy murder
which i don't want to go too much into
that this is like i read about it one of
my books
it's a good case one of those cases
where
dude gets murdered by
someone or someone's in a town
and nobody really wants to talk about it
because uh dude was a douche so you know
i think one's in the store yeah
everyone's just like i don't i don't
know who could have shot that dude i
remember that i don't know didn't see a
goddamn thing there's gonna be a good
show so i know
so yeah we're gonna talk about that on
friday night so
come by friday night 6 p.m
eastern standard time we will do another
show hopefully we won't get quite as
drunk so we'll know what we're talking
about we gotta read we gotta [ __ ] go
buy some more booze we do we cleared the
place out did we yeah that's it that's
it that was the last of the booze that's
it well at least we're not wasting
anything
well let's let's see
all right so we will see you guys friday
evening 6 p.m eastern standard time
come back
and we'll be talking about some true
crime [ __ ]
thank everybody thanks everybody for
dropping by thanks for super chats
thanks for being cool in the comments
like you always are and we'll see you
guys on friday
we'll see you later
bye